Und das ist dann im Prinzip fast dein PIN. Fast, weil wenn die erste Ziffer eine Null ist, wird daraus eine Eins gemacht.
Na das sind jetzt schon die Details.
Das sind schon die Details, ja.
Also mit anderen Worten, die PIN steht nicht im Klartext auf der Karte, sondern es stehen diverse andere Angaben auf der Karte, auf den Magnetstreifen gespeichert. Die sind auch von jedem normalen Gerät, jedem normalen Magnetlesegerät auslesbar. Man weiß auch, wo die stehen und das Einzige, was einem fehlt, um diese PIN aus diesen Daten selbst zu errechnen, so wie das ein Geldautomat tut, um eben zu überprüfen, ob deine eingegebene PIN auch die richtige ist. Das Einzige, was einem dazu fehlt, ist entweder der Institutsschlüssel oder eben noch besser der Pool-Schlüssel, diese 56-Bit. Das muss man noch mal klar sagen. Dieser Schlüssel alleine hätte man ihn, würde ausreichen und mit jeder EC-Karte überall in Europa, überall wo ein Geldautomat steht, Geld abzuheben.
Also dieser Schlüssel ist eine 64-Bit Zahl.
56-Bit.
56-Bit Zahl. Und die muss ja dann in jedem EC-Automat gleich sein.
Genau, hier ist so ein ganz geheimen, auslesegeschützten Chip drin, der sich also angeblich, so wie man ihn da rausnimmt aus dem Geldautomat zerstört, sich gleich selbst und solche Geschichten. Also das ist so eine spezielle Technik, die allerdings auch schon geknackt wurde. Es gibt jetzt sozusagen verschiedene Fragen, die da so auftauchen. Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt als Krimineller losgeht, was würde man dann am einfachsten tun, wenn man jetzt dieses Ding haben will? Also man könnte ja zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie EC-Karten klauen, oder geklaute EC-Karten werben oder was auch immer, und dann hat man in der Regel ja nicht den Schlüssel dazu. Dann kann man irgendwie anfangen zu raten, aber die Anzahl der Rateversuche ist aufgrund von so einem anderen Ding, das nennt sich Fehlbedienungszähler stark eingeschränkt. Also normalerweise darf man nur dreimal in einen falschen Pin-Code eingehen, dann wird die Karte einbehalten. Und es wäre natürlich recht lukrativ, sich diesen Poolschüssel auf irgendeine Art und Weise zu beschäftigen. Man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel auch vermuten, das ist jetzt mal das plumpeste, deswegen vielleicht ganz am Anfang, dass sich einfach jemand ein paar Geldautomaten geklaut hat und diesen Poolschlüssel sich da rausgeholt hat.
Von Geldautomaten klauen ist ja auch kein Problem.
Die wiegen ein paar hundert Kilo, die sind extra beschwert, das richtigen Tresor und so, aber es ist mittlerweile davon geredet, dass im Laufe des jetzt 15-jährigen Systems hier etwa 700 bis 900 Geldautomaten abgängig sind, wie es so schön in der amtlichen Fachsprache heißt.
So, und wenn ihr einen davon zu Hause habt, dann ruft an 0331.
Ja sag doch mal die Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110, falls ihr einen Geldautomaten zu Hause habt. Wir werden nachher die Leitung aufmachen. Moment, gibt es noch nicht viel zu reden. Wir machen gleich erstmal das Fritz-Koos-Info. Und dann erzählen wir euch noch ein bisschen mehr über EC-Karten. Und dann werden wir auch mit euch telefonieren. Dann geht es um eure Erfahrungen mit EC-Karten.
Na das ist eine Scheide von einem guten Freund aus Hamburg, von Sven Dose und die heißt Konzuma. So das ein freundlicher junger Mann mit einem etwas, ich würde mal sagen, mit so einem Olympia-Fackeldicken-Joint auf dem Körper. Aber die Scheide ist trotzdem gut.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Hochwasseralarm. Im Oderburg müssen die Einwohner von etwa 40 weiteren Ortschaften evakuiert werden. Betroffen sind rund 15.000 Menschen und halte der Krisenstab des Kreises Märkisch-Oderland mit. Grund ist ein neuer Deichrutsch bei Hohenwutzen.
Sollte der Deich brechen, wäre die Flutwelle höher als alles bisher Dagewesene. Die Bundeswehr hat den bedrohten Deich bei Hohenwutzen inzwischen soweit stabilisiert, dass Helfer nun auch wieder direkt an der Wehranlage arbeiten können. Über Stunden hinweg waren lediglich aus der Luft Sandsäcke auf die mehrfach gerissene Stelle geworfen worden.
Hubschrauber der Bundeswehr hatten in pausenlosem Einsatz das Material herbeigeschafft und zielgenau abgeworfen.
Die Chancen, den Deich überhaupt zu retten, stünden aber trotz des erfolgreichen Hubschrauber-Einsatzes lediglich bei 10 Prozent.
Samir Ibrahim, Frankfurt Oder.
Gegenmaßnahmen. Wenige Stunden nach dem Bombenanschlag in Jerusalem hat Palästinenser Präsident Arafat den Ausnahmezustand über die Autonomiegebiete verhängt. Außerdem ordnete er die Festnahme von Mitgliedern radikal islamischer Gruppen an. Inzwischen bekannte sich die islamische Untergrundorganisation Hamas zu dem Anschlag. Dabei wurden 14 Menschen getötet und mehr als 150 verletzt. Angebot. Die Brandenburger Landesregierung will zum 1. Oktober 50 zusätzliche Lehrstellen in sogenannten Kammerberufen bereitstellen. Dabei handelt es sich unter anderem um Fachinformatiker und Kaufleute für Bürokommunikation.
Wetter.
Nacht 17 bis 14 Grad, morgen vereinzelt Shower bis 24 Grad.
Verkehr.
Ich bin keine aktuellen Meldung vor.
Kassenkauf mit dem Fritz, kurz Info.
Fritz präsentiert. Das Reizflut Open Air 97 in Lauchhammer am Freitag, 1. August mit Creme 21 und Lemon Babies. Samstag, 2. August, Punko, Spice, The Melons und viele andere. Reizflut Open Air 97, 1. und 2. August im Schlosspark Lauchhammer West. Tickets unter 03574 12 18 42. 03574 12 18 42. Und wer nicht mehr nach Hause kommt, der zählt es. Aber alles nur mit Fritz.
Jetzt weiter mit Chaos Radio bei Fritz, der Computer Dämonen. Wir sind Menbreak, ready or not. Und ihr hört den Chaos Radio Blumenholen, den Computer Blumenholen bei Fritz. Es geht um EC-Karten. Wir haben gerade ein bisschen gehört, wie das funktioniert mit der PIN-Nummer, mit der 4-stelligen Zahl, die ihr eintippt um an euer Geld zu kommen.
Und jetzt kommen wir noch auf so eine kleine Besonderheit mit diesem Fehlbedienungszähler. Also ganz am Anfang, als das System eingeführt wurde, so irgendwie 83, 84 rum, da war es halt so, dass auf dem Magnetstreifen stand, eben der Fehlbedienungszähler, es war eine 3 und immer wenn man sich dann einmal vertippt hat, wurde er eben runtergezählt auf 2 und so fort und wenn dann eine 0 stand, dann wurde die Karte gleich vom Automaten einbehalten. Auf der anderen Seite waren aber diese ganzen Automaten offline, das heißt nicht miteinander vernetzt, sodass man so eine Karte auch einfach in seinem Auto, dann in so einen Magnetstreifen Schreibgläser reinstecken konnte, den man so für, naja, ein Deluxe-Modell für 1, 5, sag ich mal, erwerben kann und den dann einfach wieder hochsetzen. Also das war möglich und das ging auch. Und entsprechend konnte man dann, wenn man irgendwie oft genug rumgereist ist, sozusagen einfach die EC-Karte überall ausprobieren und dann konnte man natürlich immer wieder hochsetzen, ausprobieren und so fort. Und das war so einer der primitivsten ersten Tricks, mit dem wohl auch Leute damals losgezogen sind.
Aber das ist doch ein tierischer Aufwand.
Na klar, aber das rechnet sich auch. Und wenn du den Pimpkot hast, dann kannst du ja da auch irgendwie Diakote rausholen. Es geht ja hier um Geld und diese Scheine, wo die Leute so...
Das ist eine einmalige Investition, konstante Höhe. Da muss man das halt...
Aber es ist doch auch ein anstrengendes Leben.
Ja, es ist ein anstrengendes Leben, aber es gibt offenbar irgendwie ein anstrengendes Leben. Also ich meine, wenn du irgendwie gewohnt bist Autos zu knacken oder so, dann ist das eine relativ entspannte Methode, Geld zu verdienen. Weil du probierst ja nur ein bisschen rum, fährst ein bisschen im Auto rum, spielst ja ein bisschen mit so Tastaturen rum. Also ich meine, es gibt wahrscheinlich schon anstrengendere Methoden, Geld zu verdienen. Aber kurz zum aktuellen Stand sozusagen, mittlerweile ist das ein bisschen anders. Mittlerweile werden die Fehleingaben zentral protokolliert in einem Computer, wie behauptet wird. Und außerdem wird behauptet, dass alle Automaten in Deutschland immer online sind, oder vielmehr, dass sie zumindest online sind. Und das stimmt fast sozusagen. Vielleicht solltest du erstmal den Unterschied zwischen der Online-
und Offline-Geschichte klarhalten.
Na ja, online heißt es halt, dass die Automaten sozusagen mit einem Computer irgendwo noch vernetzt sind, der eben die Transaktion dann auch nachvollzieht, der das dann de facto vom Konto abzieht bzw. nachguckt, ob überhaupt das Geld auf dem Konto ist.
Also erstens geht es zum Beispiel inzwischen schneller, dass das Geld vom Konto runterrutscht, und dann war es vor einigen Jahren noch so, dass man, wenn auf dem Konto nichts mehr drauf war, konnte man trotzdem bei einer anderen Bank hingehen und diese damalige Höchstgelsumme von 400 Mark, die konnte man auf alle Fälle abheben, weil der Rechner noch nicht wusste, dass man nichts auf dem Konto hat. Heute geht das nur noch bei bestimmten Automaten.
Genau das heißt ja offline, dass der Automat eben nicht weiß, was irgendwie mit dem Konto eigentlich los ist, sondern sich im Grunde genommen auf die Daten des Magnetstreifens verlassen muss. Wie es eben auch im Ausland in der Regel der Fall ist, dass sie eben keine Verbindung zum Deutschen Rechenzentrum haben. Und auch in Deutschland ist das mit der Online-Behauptung, also das wird dann später ein bisschen wichtiger, deswegen erklären wir es jetzt, eben auch nur bedingt richtig. Weil zum Beispiel, ich sag jetzt mal bei der Deutschen Bank, es ist so, dass zwischen 22 und 7 Uhr morgens das Rechenzentrum sozusagen abgekapselt wird von diesen Geldautomaten, weil da nämlich eine Umbuchung von den sogenannten, ja sozusagen einfach digitalen Daten, also von den Tagesdaten auf den juristischen Datenbestand erfolgt.
Also wenn halt die Buchungen, die am Tag gemacht wurden, gegen die Daten gefahren, die tatsächlich das Geld repräsentieren, die sind halt noch mal auf einem extra Rechner, der besonders abgesichert ist, damit das Geld auch nicht verloren geht. Und da werden dann halt nachts die Transaktionen gemacht. Und in der Zeit kann man halt auch keine Kontoauszüge bekommen. Also wo man nachts keine Kontoauszüge bekommt, bekommt man nachts meistens auch immer noch Geld, dass dann die Karte schon durch ist.
Das Problem ist, dass man seine Karte bloß ist, wenn man sie in den Kontoauszugsdrucker steckt.
Nicht bei allen.
Aber gut, also damit ist sozusagen klar, es gibt auch weiterhin Offline-Automaten, es gibt natürlich auch noch im Ausland Offline-Automaten, und es gibt nach wie vor diesen Fehlbedienungszähler, der deswegen auch eine Rolle spielt, auch wenn das in der heutigen Diskussion sozusagen eher unter den Tisch fällt. Ja, jetzt wollten wir, du wolltest jetzt so eine Einlage bringen hier?
Bist du denn schon fertig mit deinem Monolog?
Ja, also wenn jetzt irgendwie keiner mir zum Fehlbedienungszähler Fragen hat, hallo, Hörer, Fragen?
Die dürfen auch noch gar nicht anrufen.
Also der Fehlbedienungszähler ist auf Spur 3 der Magnetkarte, die Spuren sind in entsprechenden ISO-Dekumenten standardisiert, und in der Zeitschrift Datenschleuder gibt es auch ein Listing, wie die Spur 3 aufgeschlüsselt ist, welche Daten da wo stehen.
Genau, und ansonsten gibt es in der IX, Oktober 91, einen recht guten Artikel, wo der ganze Quatsch drin ist, und irgendwo ist hier auch die DIN-Norm genannt.
Also die ISO-Norm für die Spur 3 ist die ISO 49.09, zum Seitenpreis von 10 Mark bei dem ISO-Verlag erhältlich. Zum Seitenpreis von 10 Mark. Das ist so ein 8-seitiges Häftchen, das kostet 60 Mark. Datenschleuder ist billiger. Für 60 Mark kriegt man ein ganzes Jahresabo mit Mitgliedschaft im Chaos Computer Club.
Sag mal, außerdem im letzten Newsletter stand irgendwie von wegen Datenschleuder sollte bei allen sein. Bei mir ist er noch nicht.
Wie?
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Dann musst du mal abonnieren.
Habe ich schon vor Jahren. Habt ihr mir gesagt, ich wollte damals bezahlen. Habt ihr gesagt, nee, lass mal.
Echt?
Kriegst du auch keine Datenschleuder?
Aber ich hab eine dabei. Ja, super.
Ich hab auch noch eine dabei.
Könnt ihr den Hörern auch eine durchreichen?
Während wir noch nach der Datenschleuder-Kram grüßen wir erstmal unsere lieben Freunde von der tollen Firma.
Schade, ne?
Das ist jetzt auch nur rechts. Das ist natürlich total doof.
Irgendetwas ist da schon wieder mit dem Zettel.
Also wir haben noch einen Wackelkontakt. Ich hab ja auch einen Wackelkontakt in meinem Kopfhörer.
Jetzt ist es wieder auf beiden Kanten.
Das klingt aber genauso.
Nein, also mein Kopfhörer hat einen Wackelkontakt. Das kommt noch dazu.
Das ist nicht mein Problem.
Das kam jetzt wieder nur auf einen Kanten an.
Tolle Cover macht ihr ja immer bei der Datenschleudern.
Ich war im Rollauf. Vielleicht nehmen wir diesen roten Faden hier mal wieder.
Ja genau, nehmen wir den roten Faden wieder. EC-Karten.
Es gibt nämlich noch eine andere Geschichte. Die betrifft ein anderes Segment der Art des Betrugs. Und das ist die Totalfälschung. Es gibt auch Leute, die kommen auf die Idee, warum überhaupt EC-Karten klauen, warum irgendwie Brustschwüssel ausrechnen und das ganze Quatsch, warum drucken wir die Dinger nicht einfach selbst. Und der Grund liegt sozusagen darin, dass die Daten eben nicht nur auf dem Magnetstreifen sind und sozusagen da in Wien nachvollzogen werden, sondern es gibt auch noch ein sogenanntes MM-Merkmal. Dieses MM-Merkmal, da schweigen sich die Banken aus verständlichen Gründen aus. Da gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Das eine wäre sozusagen eine induktive Versteckung von Daten noch in diesem Plastik. Und das andere wäre eine per Infrarot auslesbar. Da sagt Andreas vielleicht gleich noch einen Ton zu.
Ja, das ist selbstverständlich auch standardisiert, wie das oft gebaut ist. Und auf der Spur 3 stehen acht Stellen, die wiederum mit den Kartendaten korrespondieren. Das heißt, die Kartendaten werden ausgelesen und zusammen mit den induktiv Daten und dem, was in den acht Beiden auf Spur 3 steht, verrechnet und dann kommt irgendwie Null raus. Und angeblich basiert das auf RSA, aber weitere Informationen gibt es leider noch nicht.
Also das heißt, damit soll es erstens schwierig sein, Karten total zu fälschen und zweitens, von einer bestehenden Karte einfach andere Daten raufzuschreiben und dann versuchen sozusagen so zu tun, als ist man jetzt, was weiß ich, Johnny, oder als ist man irgendwie der Sender Fritz oder wie auch immer, als ist man jemand anders. Weil dann nämlich die Daten des Magnetstreifens nicht mit denen des MM Markmals korrespondieren.
Dieses MM Markmal, das wurde eingeführt 1986, als die ersten Missbrauchsfälle auftraten, da gab es auch eine AD-Radgeber-Technik-Sendung und daraufhin fühlten sich wohl Leute motiviert und haben das, was da in der Sendung gezeigt wurde, nachgebaut mit kleinen schwarzen Vorschaltkästen vor den Geldautomaten, wo die Leute halt ihre Karten reingeschoben haben, dann kamen die Karten nicht wieder raus und dann hatte man die Karte. Und die PIN haben sie rausgekriegt, indem sie weißes Pulver über die Tastatur gestreut haben und geguckt haben, wo die Fingerabdrücke waren. Da braucht man 24 Versuche und dann weiß man, wie die PIN ist.
Ja, beziehungsweise um es nochmal präzise darzustellen, also die haben folgendes gemacht. Die haben einen kleinen Kasten vor den EC-Kartenautomaten gesteckt. Da hat man seine normale Karte reingesteckt. Dann wurde eine andere Karte, eben eine, die sich in diesem kleinen schwarzen Kasten befand, in den Automaten gegeben, sodass der eingegedene PIN-Code natürlich falsch war. Weil man ja irgendwie da eine ganz andere Karte drin hatte. Sodass die dann irgendwann eingezogen wurde. Der Automat, auch korrekt gesagt, der Karte wurde eingezogen, wenn sie sich an ihre Bank, sodass der frustrierte Kunde nach Hause ging. Aber in Wirklichkeit war seine Karte ja nicht am Bankautomat, sondern in diesem kleinen Kasten. Und ja.
Ja, das MM-Merkmal ist eine Erfindung der Firma Giesige und DeVrient. Eine von diesen drei, vier Kartensicherheitsherstellern, für die es auch noch eine andere gibt und wird größtenteils nur in Deutschland verwendet. Das heißt, es gibt zwar dieses MM-Sicherheitsmerkmal, aber wenn man irgendwo anders hinfährt in Europa oder wenn man Glück hat an seinem Geldautomat, dann wird das MM-Merkmal nicht geprüft.
Also nein, das gibt es generell erstens nur in Deutschland und zweitens auch nicht immer, weil nämlich dieses MM-Merkmal noch ein anderes Merkmal hat und das ist, dass es oft ausfällt. Da gibt es verschiedene Aussagen drüber, zum Beispiel, dass es aus witterungstechnischen Gründen oftmals ausfällt, das wiederum würde dafür sprechen, dass es sich um Impravod handelt, weil das ist ja nichts weiter als Wärme sozusagen. Da gibt es verschiedene Theorien, auf gut Deutsch aber fallen diese Dinge oft auf und deswegen wird wohl auch bei sozusagen falschen Daten, die das MM-Merkmal liefert, die Karte irgendwie akzeptiert. Also da gibt es irgendwie komische Aussagen zu, die wir auch gar nicht weiter kommentieren wollen. Versuchen, von den Jürgern ein Feedback zu kriegen, ob das bis hierhin verständlich ist.
Und das ist immer schwierig.
Na ja, verstand das bestimmt keiner richtig. Ja, aber das bist nicht du. Bist du wieder da?
Ich bin ja nicht so schön.
Das ist nur recht, das ist nur recht, dass du mir mit dem Kabel hinterherlaufen.
Aber als du die Mikros dann vorhin ausgemacht hast, da ging es doch in kurzem Moment.
Bist du dir sicher, dass da ein Stereo-Ausgang ist an dem Powerbook? Ja, natürlich. Das hat mit den Mikros nichts zu tun, völlig unterschiedliche Kanäle. Das kann aber nur Kabel sein. Wackelt er nochmal? Zieh den Stecker mal so ein kleines Stück raus hinten.
Ja, klar kommt er.
So, jetzt gehts noch.
Das ist jetzt aber wieder die CD. Das hier ist der, ich will den da runterziehen, wenn er da im Stecker rumruckelt. Guck dir doch mal den Stecker an.
Der Stecker ist irgendwie rund.
Ja, aber hatte zwei... Genau, nimm mal den Kopfhörer und guck erstmal, ob das stimmt alles. So, werden wir hier verschiedene Steckerprobleme lösen, ganz mechanische Probleme scheinbar?
Nimmst du mal das Fenster ein bisschen zu? Hier ist alles voller Insekten.
Hier ist alles voller Insekten?
Hast du eine Filmik gesehen?
Hier stinkt, deswegen. Fenster zu, Fenster zu.
Nein, ich meine ein bisschen.
Gut, wir gucken mal, ob wir ein neues Kabel finden. Werdessen könnt ihr euch überlegen, was ist euch mit EC-Karten schon passiert? Habt ihr Geschichten zu diesem Thema? Seid ihr schon mal beschissen worden zum Beispiel? Oder...
Ja, lass uns das noch ein bisschen verschieben. Erstmal vielleicht doch eher die Fragen in Richtung Funktionsweise und Geschichten. Was kommt denn jetzt gleich noch? In der zweiten Stunde wollten wir ein bisschen aus den rechtlichen Fragen.
Die rufen jetzt aber schon an.
Na gut, dann nehmen sie doch mal rein.
Was die wollen?
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, hier ist Christian aus Berlin. Ich habe mal eine Frage zu dem DIR-System. Und zwar haben die doch vor einer Weile im Internet mit Sicht vernetzten Rechnern diese 56-Bit-Klisse geknackt. Und ich würde mal gerne wissen, warum eigentlich noch niemand auf die Idee gekommen ist, das für die ET-Karten zu machen.
Doch, da sind wir ja dabei. Da wollten wir eigentlich ein bisschen später zu kommen. Das ist sozusagen das Projekt, was wir gerade betreiben. Aber wir wollten erst mal erklären, warum. Ist aber eine sehr berechtigte Frage sozusagen. Man muss aber dazu sagen, die haben da schon eine Menge Rechner genommen, ne, bei 56 Bits.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall richtig. Aber ich meine, es gibt bestimmt auch eine Menge Leute, die das gerne haben würden. Aber das kommt nachher noch.
Also es wird auch passieren. Es ist auch sehr interessant zu sehen, wie derzeit die Banken darauf reagieren. Im Prinzip haben sie ja schon bekannt gegeben, dass das derzeitige Sicherheitssystem in naher Zukunft ausgetauscht werden wird.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, mit wie viel Bit verschlüsselt denn Pretty Good Privacy eigentlich die Daten?
Das kommt drauf an, da hast du ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten zu wählen. In der sozusagen bis jetzt gütigen Version 262i konntest du... Also es ist ja so, dass PGP2 irgendwie Algorithmen benutzt. Insofern ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen ab vom Thema, aber du kannst bis zu 2048 Bit RSA wählen und dann hast du schon eine einigermaßen adäquate Sicherheit.
Ja, das dauert schon ein bisschen. Gut, und dann noch eine andere Frage, wegen der Datenschleuder abonnieren, aber das...
Gut, sagen wir jetzt nochmal für alle und nachher sowieso nochmal, die Datenschleuder gibts zum Beispiel irgendwie 10 Mark einfach Rückporto, Probe-Abo, das sind dann drei Ausgaben. CCC Schwenkelstraße 85 in 2025 für Hamburg oder guckt einfach mal auf www.ccc.de, da gibts auch die Hinweise.
Das war schon eine interessante Frage.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob sie genau wissen, was das ist? Ja, hier ist Karl. Chaosradio.
Hier ist Karl. Ich hab mal eine ganz unprofessionelle Frage. Ja, denke ich auch. Und zwar, wie sieht es aus mit einer Bankkarte aus einem ganz anderen Land? Wenn ich die jetzt in Deutschland benutzen würde, was würde mit der Karte passieren, wenn ich die in einen Automaten stecke?
Hat die so ein EC-Kartensymbol oder irgendwie ein Kreditkartensymbol drauf?
Nee, das ist eine ganz normale Bankkarte von einer Bank aus einem anderen Land.
Dann würde er wahrscheinlich sagen, nehm ich nicht und spuck sie wieder aus.
Er spuckt sie aber wieder aus.
Was denn für eine Bank?
Das ist eine kanadische Bank.
Also da spuckt er sie in Zweifel wieder aus oder behält sie an?
Oh, das möchte ich nicht.
Er spuckt sie in der Regel wieder aus und sagt, dass er damit nichts anfasst. Das ist zumindest das Verhalten, was man von Geldautomaten erwarten würde, wenn er richtig programmiert ist. Also in der Regel gibt es da keinerlei Kooperationen in Bezug auf Bankkarten zwischen Amerika und Europa.
Wo hast du denn die her, Cara?
Ich war mal so kurze Zeit in Kanada und da brauchte ich ein Konto, weil ich da auch gearbeitet habe und man kriegt ja nicht sein Geld so auf die Hand.
Man braucht ja ein Konto.
Die haben ja kein Bargeld mehr, die Kanadier und die Nordamerikaner.
Nee, aber wenn man Geld verdient, also da arbeiten geht, ist es wie in Deutschland, da gibt es ja nicht mehr Lohntütchen oder so.
Aber die Karte, die wird auf jeden Fall ausschmeißen.
Und dann keine Arbeit und dann kein Konto.
Es ist ja auch in Deutschland in gewisser Hinsicht schon eine Neuerung, dass man überall in Deutschland seine Bankkarte, also seine Bankkarte, nicht seine EC-Karte, sondern nur die Institutseigene Karte überall verwenden kann. Also selbst das ist noch nicht unbedingt gewährleistet. Kreisbar Kasse hier, Kreisbar Kasse da, das funktioniert seit kurzer Zeit, aber Kanada ist ja noch außen vorn.
Ich könnte jetzt mal so richtig abstocken mit meiner Mutter.
Was, so kommen wir später.
Okay, Kara, danke. Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Wird ihr dafür dann gleich nochmal weiter, erstmal ein bisschen Infos? Oder nicht?
Nehmen wir denn noch ein neues Kabel hier für das Powerboot?
Das ist nicht das Kabel. Es ist nicht das Kabel.
Sondern?
Sondern? Na wahrscheinlich das Pult.
Kann man nicht mit einem anderen Eingang gehen?
Dann kann man einfach mal einen anderen Kanal am Pult nehmen.
Also angeblich sollte das einigermaßen funktionieren. Wir können das ja mal kurz ausprobieren.
Einen Punkt hinten noch.
Links. Eingang an dem Pult da.
Ja, ich bastel da mal. Genau. Wir basteln mal kurz und sehen uns gleich wieder. So, ihr macht jetzt die Kamera noch mal, ja?
Genau, bevor wir nämlich jetzt gleich sozusagen überleiten zu den Rechtsgeschichten, wollen wir noch ein weiteres Sicherheitsmerkmal diskutieren und das ist die Kameraüberwachung. Neuerdings sind in EC-Kartenautomaten teilweise selbst in den Automaten drin oder draußen rum angebracht zu Kameras mit sogenanntem Timelapse-Rekord an.
Genau, und die nehmen halt die ganze Zeit von dem, was da von den Automaten passiert, sobald jemand eine Karte einführt, halt so ein Bild pro Sekunde ungefähr auf eine Videokamera auf und die Prints davon kriegt man dann halt immer vorgelegt, wenn es um irgendwelchen Betrug geht. Diese Aufnahmen, also manchmal sieht man die Kameras dahin so groß in den Banken rum und manchmal sind sie halt so gerade so bei Automaten von so kleinen Banken auch eingebaut, also die gucken sich halt vom Innen über einen kleinen Spiegel vom Bildschirm an, das sieht man auch nicht wirklich. Und mit diesen Bildern wird dann halt versucht Leute zu identifizieren und hochzunehmen, die halt irgendwie alle möglichen Arten von EC-Karten betrug machen.
Wobei man dazu sagen kann, die offensichtlicher die Kamera ist, desto größer ist auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es sich um eine Attrappe handelt. Das gibt es nämlich auch.
Ja, aber so an Schwerpunktautomaten, wo halt irgendwie Probleme vorhaft auftreten, da funktionieren die Dinge in der Regel. Also jede Buchung in dem Automaten wird ja mit einem Timestamp, also mit einem Zeitstempel auf einem Drucker hinten im Automaten protokolliert. Hört man immer, wenn man in einem Automaten macht, hört man es hinten immer so, das ist der neue Nadel Drucker, der halt die ganzen Transaktionen noch mal präsentiert hat.
Ach, ich dachte immer, das ist der Typ, der mein Geld zählt.
Nee, das ist der, der dein Geld druckt. Und diese Sachen werden dann mit dem Timestamp von dem Video-Recorder verglichen und da gibt es dann auch interessante Verdächtigungen, die halt falsch geäußert werden, wenn zum Beispiel der Zeitstempel auf dem Video-Recorder nicht mit dem Zeitstempel auf diesem Drucker übereinstimmt, da wurden dann schon mehrere Mal Leute fälschlich beklagt.
Ja, wobei das ist, also vielleicht noch so mal auszuführen, das ist ein schwieriges Problem. Also auf den Videobildern ist immer eingeblendet, Datum, Uhrzeit und wenn die Uhrzeit des Videorekorders einfach mal falsch geht um zwei Minuten, dann kann es dann zu Fall zuvor zu Ordnung kommen. Es gibt zum Beispiel einen Gutachten oder einen Fall, den ich auf dem Tisch hab, da hat jemand also irgendwie am Automaten Geld abgehoben und das Geld wurde aber komischerweise seinem Konto nie irgendwie abgehoben. Also es wurde seinem Konto nie irgendwie abgezogen. Und jetzt wird er verdächtigt, irgendwie mit einer fremden Karte da abgehoben zu haben. Und da fängt es dann irgendwie so an. Und ob solche Videobilder überhaupt beweiskräftig sind, Riesenprobleme und Geschichten. Aber gut, die Überwachungstechnologie.
Vielleicht sollte man gleich noch die andere Seite dieser Kameratechnologie erwähnen, dass halt nicht nur die Banken sich halt Kameras bedienen, sondern halt auch alle möglichen Betrüger, die halt kleine Videokameras und Automaten installieren, um halt die PIN auszuspähen und den Leuten... Na, wieso? Das passt doch eigentlich dazu. Also der Trick ist halt sozusagen der simpelste Taschenspieler Trick, den man sich vorstellen kann. Dann ist halt eine kleine Kamera, die guckt halt auf deine Hände, welche PIN du eingibst und dann wirst du halt angrempeln. Der wird deine Karte gezockt und dann wird die halt hinterher leer gemacht. Ging vor ein paar Monaten, fast einem Jahr auch durch die Presse und ist es wohl aber immer noch in Anwendung, weil halt der Trick so simpel ist, dass sich da auch jemand gegen wirklich wehren kann, wenn man beugt sich halt so weit darüber, dass halt die PIN nicht ausgespielt werden kann.
Wobei, dann müssen wir gleich auf den Delux-Fall eingehen. Nämlich in Hamburg gab es diesen schönen Fall, da hat ein Tankstellen-Pächter seine Raumüberwachungskamera auf eben seinen POS-Talbe gerichtet. POS sind diese Point of Sale, wo man ja auch mit seiner EC-Karte mittlerweile mit PIN-Code zahlen kann, sich sogar Geld sozusagen rausgeben lassen kann. Und hat also so den PIN-Code erfahren, eben durch seine Raumüberwachungskamera und hat nebenbei noch den Magnetstreifen unter dem Tisch mit einem kleinen Laptop kopiert, eben zwischen der Kabelverbindung zwischen diesem kleinen Terminal und seiner Kasse. Und das ging dann sozusagen auch in die Rechtsgeschichte ein. Aber das fiel irgendwann auf, weil eben die ganzen Leute dann irgendwie Probleme mit ihren Karten hatten und alle hatten eben gemeinsam das R, der Tankstellen-Pächter und so fort.
Kommt ihr später zur Haftung oder kann ich da mal dazuschreiben?
Genau, da kommen wir später zu. Das wollen wir eigentlich jetzt in einer zweiten Stelle machen. Nee, die ist jetzt noch nicht. Entweder du nimmst jetzt noch einen Hörer oder du machst jetzt noch ein bisschen Musik und dann, weil das ist echt...
Das File Sharing ausschalten und dann...
Das ist schon ausgeschaltet. Das wollte ich aber nicht hören jetzt.
Aber egal, Hauptsache... Es geht ja darum, dass wir hier einen Laptop haben, der jetzt endlich funktioniert. Das war nicht der Laptop. Sind das jetzt Morphs oder MPEGs oder was ist das?
Das sind jetzt MPEG-3s, jetzt hören wir gleich was aus dem Film Akira. Wir haben aber auch wieder Mods-Files dabei von unserem Hauskomponisten, der schon in einer der letzten Sendungen sehr interessantes Material geschickt hat. Da haben wir wieder was Neues.
War das der, der auch mal hier war? Genau.
Und dann werden wir uns das auch noch anhören.
Naja, die einen technischen Probleme sind gelöst, der anderen noch nicht.
Wir versuchen mal einen anderen MPEG-Player.
Aber wie hört man denn zumindest, dass alles...
Nicht gut sind hier.
aus dem Rechner passiert ist.
Es sind nicht die Probleme, die sind annähernd überhaupt nicht genutzt.
Ja Eine Minute nach elf und ihr hört Chaosradio, den Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Das geht um EC-Karten, Sicherheit, wie funktionieren die Dinger eigentlich und was jetzt Thema in der zweiten Stunde?
Und jetzt kommen wir endlich zur Haftungsfrage, nämlich zum eigentlichen Problem, die diese Karten mit sich bringen. Als Kunde einer solchen EC-Karte unterschreibt man die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen, die annähernd bei allen Instituten gleich sind und insbesondere eine sogenannte Sorgfalzklausel oder auch Sorgfalzpflicht des Kunden enthalten. Das heißt, als Inhaber einer EC-Karte verpflichtet man sich, den PIN-Code, das also einem ermöglicht, am Geldkarten Geldautomaten Geld abzuheben, eben niemanden mitzuteilen, nicht zusammen mit der Karte zusammen in einem Portemonnaie aufzubewahren, nicht auf die Karte zu notieren und so weiter und so fort, was ja auch erstmal alles verständlich und vernünftig klingt. Wenn nun aber der Fall eins wird, dass man zum Beispiel seines Portemonnaies beglaut wird und es irgendeinem doch irgendwie gelingt, in dem Zwischenraum, also jetzt der Fall, man stellt fest, sein Portemonnaie ist weg, man sperrt diese Karte, nachdem man das bemerkt hat natürlich, meldet den Liebstahl und so fort, aber trotzdem ist es irgendwie in der Zwischenzeit zu Abhebungen am Automaten gekommen. Jemand hat da vielleicht ein paar hundert, vielleicht ein paar tausend Mark abgehoben und nun hat man sozusagen für diesen Zwischenzeit ein Problem. Man muss nämlich seiner Bank wegen dieser Sorgfalspflicht beweisen, dass seinem geklauten Portemonnaie eben kein Zettel mit dem PIN-Code beilag, dass auf seiner Karte nicht der PIN-Code notiert war und so fort. Und das kann man in der Regel natürlich nicht, weil was das Portemonnaie ja gerade ausmacht, ist, dass es irgendwie weg ist. Das ist sozusagen ein ganz prinzipielles Problem. Zum einen, nämlich wie geht man damit um? Wer soll da irgendwie haften? Und zum anderen äußert sich das denn so, dass also alleine uns hier so ein paar hundert Fälle mittlerweile vorliegen, die sich im Laufe der Jahre so angesammelt haben, wo eben Leuten genau das passiert. Und dann passiert Folgendes. Erstens, das Geld ist erstmal weg und zweitens, die Banken sagen, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Sie tun nur so, als ist ihnen ja Portemonnaie geklaut worden, da gibt es ja überhaupt keinen Beweis für. Sie tun nur so, als hat der Dieb irgendwie den PIN-Code erraten oder was auch immer. In Wirklichkeit sind sie ein Betrüger. Und solche Leute bekommen dann also in der Regel ein Ermittlungsverfahren wegen Betrugs, wegen Vortäuschung einer Straftat und dann gibt es noch so ein paar andere Delikte. Und das heißt, es ist sozusagen in der Tat dann juristisch drittig, weil als Kunde muss man dann entweder eben beweisen, dass der Dieb irgendwie in den PIN-Code gekommen ist oder dass er ihn vielleicht doch anhand der Daten des Manierstreifens errechnen konnte.
Wie ist denn das prinzipiell?
Ich meine, bisher, also ohne EC-Karten, als es die noch nicht gab, da war das natürlich relativ schwierig, fremdes Geld abzuheben, weil ich brauchte einen Ausweis dazu und Unterschriften musste vor Ort sein, ich musste mich also mit Menschen unterhalten, das ist ja dann doch noch eine Schwelle. Und jetzt muss ich plötzlich bei solchen Geschichten, also an sich die Banken wollen ja, dass ich die EC-Karte benutze, weil bla bla bla, die Geschichte kennen wir ja. Und trotzdem bin ich in der Nachweispflicht, wenn damit irgendwas passiert. Das ist eine rechtlich völlig neue Situation, also die wird ja jetzt noch öfter auf uns zukommen mit digitalen Medien und so weiter, dass man was nachweisen muss, was eigentlich nicht nachzuweisen ist. Also ich kann ja, wie soll ich beweisen, dass ich keinen Zettel in meinem Portemonnaie hatte, das ist so gut wie unmöglich.
Ja klar, ich meine, das steht und fällt ja sozusagen mit der Behauptung der Banken, dass eben dieser PIN-Code völlig sicher sei und dass es eben völlig unmöglich ist für ein Dieb, an so ein PIN-Code zu belangen. Und bislang war die Rechtsprechung allerdings aufgrund sozusagen der mangelnden Informationen, also es gab einfach keinen, der sich hingestellt hat und gesagt hat, hier der PIN-Code ist ganz einfach, aber rechnen wir mal und so fort. Weil wenn das jemand irgendwie tatsächlich mal rausgefunden haben sollte, also zum Beispiel, indem jemand diesen Poolschlüssel auf irgendeinen Weg bekommen hat, dann ist er damit vermutlich stinkend reich geworden. Er hat sich aber ausgerechnet, dass er als Sachverständiger gut auch da das Gericht vielleicht 2, 50 Mark verdienen kann und als irgendwie organisierter Krimineller mit diesem Poolschlüssel 250.000 Mark am Tag. Dann irgendwie, ja, da ist es nicht richtig vorangekommen. Und jetzt gab es dieses Jahr sozusagen ein relativ spektakuläres Gerichtsurteil, wo eben erstmals ein Oberlandesgericht gesagt hat, Moment mal, da gibt es irgendwie doch Möglichkeiten. Und in diesem Fall das Institut dann eben dazu verdonnert hat, den Betrag doch zu zahlen und so fort. Das war ein Fall bei der Postbank, wo A, der Mensch relativ flüssig beweisen konnte, dass ihm die Karte geklaut wurde, weil die wurde ihm nämlich an seinem Arbeitsplatz geklaut. Und B, dass er also diesen Zeitpunkt, wo die ganzen Abhebungen gemacht wurden, er da gar nicht, ja, das sozusagen gar nicht gemacht haben konnte und auch keine seiner Angehörigen und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt kommen wir vielleicht gleich ein bisschen darauf, also was da vor Gericht passiert ist, ist zum einen, dass dieser Fall natürlich eln-seitenweise irgendwie erörtert wurde, vor allem aber, dass es eben zwei Gutachter gab, die jeweils untersucht haben, was für Möglichkeiten der Dieb denn hätte, auf diesen PIN-Code zu kommen. Zum Beispiel eben durch Ausspähen, zum Beispiel eben durch diese Geschichten, die wir vorhin erzählt haben mit den Kameras und den Ölflecken auf der Tastatur und so fort. Aber diesen Fall zeichnete aus, dass der Benutzer, also dem die Karte geklaut worden war, damit noch überhaupt nie an einem Geldautomaten Geld abgehoben hatte, weil er nämlich den PIN-Code vor zwölf Jahren, als er ihn mitgeteilt bekommen hat, gleich vernichtet hat. Und das war sozusagen das ausschlaggebende Argument, weil das konnte er auch beweisen, dass er damit noch nie Geld abgehoben hatte. Seine Frau konnte bezeugen, dass er diesen PIN-Code gleich in eine Tonne getreten hatte. Und ja, da standen sie erstmal da und haben dann irgendwie sich überlegt, hm ja, Missbrauch, schön, ja, vorhanden und Ausspähen geht irgendwie nicht, also muss es noch andere Möglichkeiten geben. Und dann wurde, und das ist sozusagen sehr spannend zu lesen, und haben wir auch deswegen in unserer Datenschleuder jetzt abgedruckt in der aktuellen. Ein Gutachter hat eben da über, ich glaube, 20 Seiten oder so dann eben aufgeführt, was für Möglichkeiten er da irgendwie sieht, auf diesen PIN-Code zu kommen. Blätter, Moment.
So, und diese 20 Seiten lese ich jetzt mal vor.
Nee, die lest du nicht vor, mach doch mal Mutten.
Also einer der Dinge, die halt bei diesem Gutachten rauskam, war, dass es gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeiten für das Vorkommen von Zahlen im PIN gibt. Also die Zahlen, die man als PIN bekommt, sind bei weitem nicht gleich verteilt, wie man es erwarten würde. Also es ist nicht gleichwahrscheinlich, dass man da vorne eine andere Zahl hat als ihn und dergleichen Dinge. Also es ist so, dass Zahlen zwischen 1 und 5 kommen halt häufiger vor als andere Zahlen.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz, da kommen wir jetzt nochmal zurück zu dieser PIN-Code Berechnung, was wir vorhin erzählt haben mit den Pool-Schlüsseln. Da gibt es nämlich diese Besonderheit der Umwandlung.
Ja, also nach der Verschlüsselung mit dem DES liegt ja wieder ein Ergebnis von 16 Bytes vor. Und von diesen 16 Bytes werden 4, ne 16 Nibbles, also jeweils 4 Bit, werden 4 ausgewählt und das sind Hex-Ziffern zwischen 0 und F logischerweise.
Kannst du mal kurz dem Chaosradio-Hörer das mit den Hex-Ziffern nochmal kurz erklären? Nein, nicht gut, nein.
Klare Antwort.
Also nach der Dessverschüßung kommt ein Ergebnis zwischen 0 und 15 raus mit der gleichen Wahrscheinlichkeit. Und wenn das Ergebnis halt ab A liegt, also größer, gleich 10 ist, werden nochmal 10 abgezogen, sodass also statistisch gesehen Zahlen 0 bis 5 je zweimal vorkommen und zahlen 6 bis 9 nur einmal. Hinzu kommt erschwerend noch, dass Pins nicht mit einer 0 beginnen dürfen, und deshalb Nullen auf eine 1 gemerkt werden. So ist zum Beispiel die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Pincode mit einer 1 anfängt 25% beträgt.
Also ums nochmal kurz zu erläutern, normalerweise gibt's eben bei der Umwandlung...
25%? 100% ist das Ganze, es gibt 9 Ziffern.
Na Moment, nein, es gibt 4, es gibt 16 Ziffern. Na Moment, das geht ja von F, G, D, S, 4, C, D, 7 mal ziffern.
Also das ist die...
Also die PIN hat 4 Stellen und jede Stelle ist eine Hexziffer. Und für die Hexziffer gibt es nach der DES-Verschlüsselung 16 Möglichkeiten, nämlich 0 bis F sind 4 Bit. Und ja, das können wir einfach mal durchzählen. Also wenn es eine 0 ist, wird es eine 1. Ist es eine 1, wird es auch eine 1. Wenn es eine 10 ist, 10 minus 10 ist 0. 0 wird wieder 1, das ist eine 1. Und 11 minus 10 ist auch 1. Das heißt, 4 von den 16 sind eine 1. Und damit sind es 25 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Gut, ich wollte es nur genau wissen. Kann er mal danach machen.
Ähnlich gestaffelt sind dann Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die anderen Zahlen, sodass man also allein ohne irgendwelche Kartentaten zu kennen, schon nach ungefähr 700 Rate versuchen, statt wie man sich das eigentlich denkt nach 5000 versuchen, die gültige Pin mit 50 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit trifft.
Beziehungsweise dann gibt es eben noch eine Besonderheit, dass es nämlich niemals eine Pin 4 gleiche Zimmerziffern hat, es sei denn einer der Hörer hat eine solche. Das wäre sehr interessant. Die Banken streiten das zumindest ab. Ist aber interessant, weil dadurch verringert sich die Anzahl der insgesamt möglichen Pins ja noch einmal. Und es gibt also deswegen sozusagen eine Liste von 32 Pins, die sehr viel häufiger auftreten als alle anderen. Die findet man auch bei www.radgebar-technik.de oder irgendwo dort. Da haben die mal einen Beitrag darüber gemacht. Und das ist dann also eine Liste, der insgesamt häufiger auftritt in Pins, die man dann sozusagen durch Probieren auswählen könnte. Und so, dass das Gericht dann letztendlich eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von...
1 zu 150 Annahmen.
Nee, das war mit Offset, dazu komm ich gleich noch.
Ach so, ja, genau, das war die Gesamtnachrichtung.
Also hier steht 1 zu 682.
Also alleine mit den...
Allein aus dem blauen raus, aus dem generellen Berechnungsverfahren. Jetzt kommt aber noch was dazu. Nachdem die Kartendaten mit Test verschlüsselt wurden, hat man ja den PIN, wenn mit dem Institutsschlüssel verschlüsselt wurde. Wird mit dem Poolschlüssel verschlüsselt, ist das Ergebnis natürlich ein anderes. Aber da man ja bei seiner Bank und bei anderen Banken denselben PIN hat, kommt dann noch mal ein sogenannter Offset ins Spiel. Der steht auf Spur-3 der Karte. Das heißt, bei Poolschlüsselüberprüfungen wird hinterher noch der Offset drauf addiert und dann ergeben sich wieder Zahlen, die genauso verteilt sind wie die Original-Pins. Das heißt, Null am Anfang tritt nicht auf. Wo die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die bei der Berechnung mit Institutsschlüssel als auch die bei der Berechnung mit Poolschlüssel verwendet werden, zusammenfasst, kommt man auf eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 150.
Das ist nicht so viel, wie die Banken immer behaupten.
Das ist deutlich weniger, als die Banken immer behaupten.
Also, Lottospielen, sehr viel unwahrscheinlicher da, sechs Richtige zu haben, als bei vier Richtige bei der PIN-Nummer. Wollen wir jetzt langsam mal die Telefon aufmachen?
Wäre eine Möglichkeit.
0331 für Potsdam, ich kann es auch so machen.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist gescheitert. 0331 für Potsdam, 74 81 110.
Ihr könnt jetzt anrufen und uns von euren Erfahrungen mit EC-Karten berichten. Wenn ihr irgendwelche guten Geschichten, witzige, interessante Geschichten habt, ruft uns an. Und wenn ihr eine vierstellige PIN-Nummer habt, falls es jemanden gibt, der viermal die gleiche Zahl als PIN-Nummer hat, das würde uns auch interessieren. Bis wir mit euch reden, ein bisschen Goldi. Wir stellen dir mal eine kleine Statistik auf. Erster Anrufer ist Dexer. Hi Dexer. Das ist die erste Ziffer deiner PIN-Nummer.
Nur die erste Ziffer.
Nur die erste Ziffer überwacht.
Wir schreiben das nur auf, um eine kleine Statistik nachher zu haben. Wir wissen ja nicht wie du heißt, wo du wohnst.
Und deine Fragen?
Wir können ja unsere auch mal sagen. Obwohl bei uns wirst, weißt man ja wer wir sind.
Ich hab eine EC-Karte und die erste Ziffer eine 1 ist.
Ich hab zwei EC-Karten, also eine ganz normale, also so eine Sparkassenkarte. Und dann eine EC-Karte und die fangen beide mit 1 an. Also schon nochmal drei 1 hier. Und bei euch?
Vier.
Ich hab keine EC-Karte, das wird viel zu unsicher. Ich hab keine EC-Karte.
Okay, Frank. Zwei und vier. Zwei und vier.
Guck mal, schon dreimal die 4, dreimal die 1. So, jetzt Frank, deine zweite Ziffer.
Gute Freude.
Dexter, du wolltest aber was ganz anderes erzählen eigentlich.
Ja, genau. Und zwar hab ich mal, also ich war mal bei der Bank quasi, wollte halt Geld abholen, war bei einer fremden Bank, also nicht bei meiner Hausbank. Hab dann meine Karte reingesteckt, hab dann so gesagt, ja, gib mal Geld und so. Und dann haben wir dann erst mal drei Minuten gewartet, vier Minuten gewartet, zum vier Minuten gewartet, dann hab ich abgebucht gedolft. Na ja, dann kam die Karte drauf und quasi ich dann zum Kontrausflugsdrucker auf den Tag später gegangen und das Geld war abgebucht 100 Mark.
War irgendwie lustig.
Aber das stand auch auf dem Geldautomatenstand drauf, der Vorgang wurde abgebucht.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen eine der vielen Möglichkeiten, die in diesem Gutachten auch aufgezählt sind, was es da so an konstruktiven Mängeln bei den Geldautomaten selbst gab. Zum Beispiel gab es Automaten, wo Leute durch Pappstreifen, die sie an irgendeiner Stelle diese Schachtes da justiert haben, also das Geld irgendwie umgelenkt hat, sodass das dann nie rausgekommen ist aus dem Automaten. Andere waren besonders schlau und haben, wenn sie zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, 150 Mark, kommen vielleicht 350er, dann haben sie sich nur den mittleren Schein genommen und der Geldautomat und die anderen Scheine haben sie sozusagen dagelassen. Der Geldautomat dachte dann, es wurde überhaupt kein Geld entnommen, hat das sozusagen wieder zurückgebucht, dem Konto wurde also gar nichts abgehoben und so hat man immerhin schon mal ein Fuffi gemacht. Na, das war ein bestimmter Geldautomat. Ja, ich meine, das ist einer der vielen Gründe, warum sie mittlerweile da in Kameras irgendwie rangebracht haben. Also da irgendwie...
Es ist auch so, wenn das eine passiert, dass das Geld nicht rauskommt, als auch wenn das andere passiert, dass man Geld rausnimmt und der Geldautomat denkt, es wäre kein Geld rausgekommen, fällt das natürlich auf. Weil die genau wissen, wie viel Geld da drin steckt und die auch Protokolle fahren und die Protokolle auch mit den Kameraprotokollen korrelieren können. Das heißt, wenn so was passiert, dass dein Geld dann nicht rauskommt, dann musst du am nächsten Tag zur Filiale gehen und Druck machen, dass sie das Geld nachzählen und dann werden sie feststellen, dass da tatsächlich ein Hundert zu viel drin ist. Die geht noch weiter?
Also sie haben dein Geld sozusagen nicht gefunden?
Genau. Und dann bin ich zu einer anderen Bank gegangen und hab dann mal gefragt, ob sie das machen können. Das hat dann erstmal gedauert. Und da hat sie mir, hat die Frau mir am Telefon gesagt, ja, wär auch nichts zu verdienen. Und dann nach monatelangen, also nach einem Monat irgendwie, nach Rechnungsabschluss, war mein Geld letztlich wieder da.
Bei welchen Banken hast du gefragt, ob das Geld da ist, wo der Geldautomat stand?
Bei der Deutschen Bank.
Also, Sekunde, langsam. Ist das die Bank, also auch die Filiale, wo der Geldautomat stand, wo das passiert ist?
Das weiß ich eigentlich nicht. Also bei dem Abbruch, das war die Grundkreditbank.
Hast du die mal gefragt, ob sie das Geld wieder gefunden haben?
Na, bei der war ich. Die haben einen riesen Sitz. Bei der war ich und die hat dann angerufen und gesagt, ne, haben wir nicht gefunden.
Weißt du noch ungefähr wann das war?
Wir wissen es ja noch.
Ich meine, es gibt eine Menge Fälle, wir führen nämlich sowieso so eine kleine Sammlung. Es gab ja auch bei der Berliner Bank, wo ein paar Fälle, oder war es Berliner Sparkasse?
Die mit dem Kontoausdrucker? Oder welche Nummer?
Nee, die, wo irgendwie die Geldautomaten mit unter mehr Geld ausgespuckt haben, als sie eigentlich sollten. Und die Bank hat dann irgendwie so eine Stellungnahme abgegeben. Wir haben da aus Versehen einen Chip von einem Spielautomaten eingebaut, oder irgendwie so ein Bullshit dann wieder.
Vielleicht bauen sie demnächst ja auch noch Hebel rechts an die Geldautomaten.
Also die Standardausrede bei Banken, wenn sie ein Softwareproblem mit einem Geldautomaten haben, ist immer, also was sie der Presse sagen, da wurde versehentlich irgendwie die Software von einer Zapfsäule von einer Tankstelle eingebaut, oder die Software von einem Spielautomaten, beides ist ein totaler Blutsinn.
Es gibt zwei Leute, die im WWW-Chat ihre alten PIN-Nummern von alten Karten durchgegeben haben, und die fangen beide mit 1 an. Ich schreibe also mal hier für die Statistik zwei weitere 1 auf.
Ich kann es sonst gar nicht, wenn wir sie dann auch noch machen. Aber wir haben da noch einen zweiten Hörer in, denkst du oder nicht?
Man sollte vorsichtig sein mit der Ausgabe seiner alten PINs, weil es durchaus sein kann, wenn man zum Beispiel mal eine Kundenkarte hatte, dann eine PIN hatte und dann später eine EC-Karte bekommt, dass man eine EC-Karte mit derselben Kartenfolgenummer bekommt. Das ist dann zwar eine andere Karte, aber es sind dieselben Karten Daten. Die Bankleitzahl ist gleich, die Kontonummer ist gleich und die Kartenfolgenummer ist gleich. Was heißt, die PIN ist gleich? Also mir ist das passiert. Ich hatte bei der Deutschen Bank eine Kundenkarte, dann war das später eine EC-Karte und hatte eine identische PIN.
Guck an!
Womit wir aber nicht von...
Das war welche?
Wo wohnst du? Martin, hi Martin!
Ja, kräftig.
Ihr klingt recht leise in meinem Telefon.
Da kann ich nichts dran ändern gleich.
Also ich stelle mir deinen Kabel kaputt.
Wenn du uns nur rechts in deinem Telefon hörst, dann ist das Kabel. Was hast du erlebt mit EC? Was ist denn deine erste Zahle?
Na, die habe ich vergessen. Schade. Egal, ich kann euch meine alte sagen.
Die ist 8838.
Danke schön.
Ein echter Ausnahmefall.
Ich hätte eher ein anderes Problemchen. Ihr redet zwar gerade über EC-Karten, aber ich beschäftige mich mehr mit Telefonkarten, die zu knacken. Und da habe ich mir schon so ein kleines Lesegerät besorgt, ein Schreibgerät.
Wie soll denn das gehen?
Ich dachte ihr habt davon Ahnung. Meine erste Frage ist nämlich, ich habe mir aus dem Internet und so schon ein bisschen Datenmaterial besorgt und Infoblätter. Aber niemand kann mir so richtig sagen, ob man eine Telefonkarte überhaupt wieder richtig aufladen kann.
Aufladen kann man sie in der Praxis nicht. Theoretisch wurde mal versucht, das einzubauen, um die Karten zu recyceln. Das ist aber Unsinn, wird mittlerweile nicht mehr gemacht. Und was man natürlich machen kann, ist Karten nachbauen. Aber das ist halbwegs kompliziert.
Und elegant.
Und dass man irgendeinen Rohling nimmt, das gibt es sicherlich auch. Das sind ja nur irgendwelche Counterkarten, irgendwelche Counterprozessoren, die nicht als Hexadezimal rechnen, sondern oktal.
Schwierigkeiten haben, eine Karte zu finden, die einen eigenen Takt hat. Also eine eigene Taktgenerierung auf dem Chip.
Also müsste man, wenn überhaupt, dann höchstest du da irgendwie einen Computer dran, einen Laptop oder so, der das simuliert.
Nein, das ist doch wie in der Praxis.
Und in der Praxis macht man das so, dass man einen Controller und einen Taktgenerator auf die Karte draufbaut und die dann abschleift, sozusagen eine Aussparung in der Karte unterbringt.
Also um es nur mal kurz zu, ist es relativ primitiv. Du brauchst einfach nur den Datenverkehr zwischen einer ganz normal käuflich erworbenen Telefonkarte und der Kartenzelle mit protokollieren und denen nachbilden. Und mehr braucht man da eigentlich gar nicht, sozusagen.
Der Rest der Information findet sich in der normalen Tagespresse immer mal wieder, wenn sie irgendwelche Leute hochziehen, dass die dann hübsche Bilder von den Karten, die sie hochgenommen haben. In der BZ sind oft solche Dinge drinne.
Naja, die lese ich nicht.
Ja, sollte man gelingtlich tun.
Zumindest, wenn man Telefonkarten fällt schon.
Martin, danke!
Alles klar, tschüss!
Und morgen werden alle BZ-Lehrer als Telefonkarten festgefasst.
Zwei haben wir hier noch aus dem Chat, eine Zwei ist dazugekommen, die ist neu. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Manfred, was sind deine erste Ziffer?
Meine ist die Zwei.
Nicht schlecht.
Nicht schlecht, ja.
Ganz gut, die Zwei.
Manfred, was hast du erlebt mit EC-Karten oder was hast du für eine Frage?
Ich hab eine Frage und zwar, wenn man eine neue PIN-Nummer bekommt, ist das automatisch muss er dann eine neue Karte bekommen.
Das ist richtig. Doch, also es gibt gewisse Außenhandel.
Nein, eine Kartenfolgenummer, die sich dann ändert nicht. Das ist eine neue Karte. Du hast doch gefragt, wenn du eine neue Karte bekommst, richtig?
Nein, wenn ich jetzt die Karten und die PIN-Nummer vergessen habe, und die neue habe, muss ich doch eine neue Karte bekommen.
Das ist in der Tat richtig. In der Praxis wird das so gemacht, dass du die alte PIN zugeschickt kriegst. Allerdings müssen wir noch mal kurz ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Und zwar ist es bei einigen Banken so, dass sämtliche Bankautomaten, also der Bank selber online sind, sodass man nicht das Problem hat, dass man den Offset da so anlegen muss, dass er immer mit der Bank-Schlüsselberechnung übereinstimmt, sondern dass die PIN einfach bei deiner Bank online geprüft wird, nicht nach diesem Verfahren. Und dann kann der Offset so gewählt werden, dass deine Wunsch-PIN dabei rauskommt. Dann wird der Offset auf der Karte geändert. Das geht aber nur bei einigen Banken. Bei den meisten Banken geht das nicht.
Achso. Und wie ist das, wenn eine Karte gesperrt wird? Das hab ich auch nicht verstanden. Weil die kann ja doch nur in der eigenen Bank gesperrt werden. Und nicht weltweit.
Nein, es ist schon so, dass die Automaten intern auch eine Festplatte haben. Und in gewissen Abständen sind die alle mal online für den Moment. Und es gibt sogenannte Blacklist, wo denn die gesperrten, oder die zu sperrenden Karten für mir in einer Datei gespeichert sind. Die wird da schon durchgetickert, bevor sozusagen deine Karte zur weiteren Bearbeitung freigegeben wird.
Ach so, weil sonst wird ja nur rechnerisch der PIN geprüft.
Deswegen war mir das nicht klar.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber ich meine, dazu kann man sozusagen als Randinformation erwähnen, dass es zwar eine Blacklist gibt, aber keine Whitelist. Und da möge sich jetzt jeder selber seine Gedanken machen, was ich damit ausführen wollte.
Ganz viel Anrufer hier. Im Moment ist der Stand bei den ersten Ziffern der PIN-Nummern. Da braucht ihr übrigens insofern...
Eigentlich bräuchte ich mir wenn, dann komplette Datensätze. Die Leute sagen, man konnte noch mal auf Anteile setzen. Es können auch abgelaufene Karten sein, Kartenfolgenummer und PIN-Kursus haben. Dann kann man damit auch was anfangen.
Wir haben also 6 Einzen bisher, 4 Zweinen, 3 Vieren und eine Acht.
Genau, wenn jemand weiß, was die iterative Analyse nach Adler ist, möge er anrufen.
Wenn jemand was weiß?
Du hattest eine Theorie dazu, kein Wissen.
Nein, das hat mir Pausch persönlich aktuell.
Da haben wir was zu verlosen. Was muss man wissen, um hier was tolles zu kriegen?
Wissen, was die iterative Analyse nach Adler ist.
Na ja, gut, wenn das jemand weiß, anrufen. Die iterative Analyse nach Adler. Sollen wir sagen, was es gibt? Es gibt ein brandneues, super geniales T-Shirt, das steht drauf Microsoft Attacks, und zwar im Schriftzug von Marsh Attacks.
Und zwar für denjenigen, der uns entweder jetzt heute am Telefon hier auf Chaosradio oder über den IC-Kanal den Pool-Schlüssel durchgehen kann. Oder aber für denjenigen, der die beste erläuternde Kommentierung der iterativen Analyses nachatet. Also wir schicken dieses T-Shirt danach uns heutzutage anonym an irgendwelche. Wie machen wir das? An anonyme Remailer.
Hi, ich hab natürlich auch mal wieder die 4.
Ich wollte euch mal fragen, was das eigentlich mit diesen Dingern auf sich hat, was in manchen Kaufhäusern haben, wo du deine EC-Karte irgendwie hinniebst an der Karte und deine PIN eintippst. Haben die da den Poolschlüssel in ihren Registrierkassen oder wie funktioniert das?
Nein, also da gibt es zwei verschiedene Methoden. Das sind zum einen sogenannte POS Terminals, also Point of Sale. Zum Teil kannst du da auch ohne die Eingabe deines PIN-Codes Transaktionen machen. Das ist dein Bank-Einzugsverfahren. Da wo du deinen PIN-Code eingibst, sind diese Automaten online. Das heißt, da gibt es eine Datex-P-Verbindung und so weiter und so fort. Es soll allerdings auch, sagen wir mal, Kaufinstitute geben, die aus betriebswirtschaftlichen Gründen nicht wirklich den PIN online durchgeben, sondern die da mehr oder weniger eine gewisse Pauschal-Akzeptanz betreiben.
Ich war zum Beispiel an einem Baumarkteinkaufen, wo ich meinen PIN zweimal eingeben musste. Das war der Standard und ich musste sie deshalb zweimal eingeben, damit verglichen wurde, ob sie gleich ist. Dann haben wir wahrscheinlich am Abend festgestellt, ob die Transaktion jetzt legal war oder nicht.
Und zwar einfach aus den Gründen, weil es für diese Kaufinstitute oder wie man sie auch mal nennt, einfach günstiger ist pauschal alles entgegenzunehmen und die Scheiße zu verrechnen. Und den Missbrauch, der da entsteht, dann vom Gewinn abzuziehen, als diese Online-Transaktion zu machen. Weil zu so einer Online-Struktur gehört halt schon Datex-P-Anschluss und irgendwelche Computer, die miteinander vernetzt sind, und Festplatten und Wartungspersonal und und und. Und eventuell ist es für die, wenn einfach günstiger, da ein bisschen pauschal.
Gehen aus Sicherheitsgründen verschiedene Kaufhäuser auf dieses System mit der Einzugsberechtigung? Also, dass du einfach deine Karte nur wegen der Konto-Nummer... Ach, das ist billiger.
Sie machen es meistens nur zum bestimmten Betrag. Also, dieses Laststoffverfahren findest du häufig zum Beispiel in Buchleben oder so, wo meistens nur so ein Beträge bis zu 100 oder 200 an den Markt geht, also wo du halt irgendwie keine Kühlschränke und Radio-Recorder rausträgst.
Jetzt hat immer so ein bisschen Suspekt, so von mir fühle ich mich ja, weil man gibt da irgendwie seine, steckt seine Karte rein und gibt dann seine PIN-Nummer noch ein. Aber dass die irgendwie mal fake waren, so ne Dinger, das ist irgendwie noch nicht vollkommen.
Hatte ich doch vorhin erwähnt, also zum Beispiel eben diese Tankstellen-Geschichte, wo du warst zwischen POS-Terminal und Kasse, dann dein Laptop noch in einer seriellen Schnittstelle.
Und die andere Variante, dass die Überwachungskamera in der Tankstelle zufällig Richtung Terminal zeigte.
Was kann der denn da rein sehen?
Roland, ich sag schon mal Tschüss zu dir.
Ich hab noch ne andere Frage.
Liezen die EC-Automaten noch irgendwelche Hardware-merkmale?
Sprich, irgendwie gucken die sich dieses komische Hologramm an? Oder kann man das wie einen Frankenrohling beschreiben?
Die gucken sich nur noch das, was wir vorhin kurz erwähnt haben, ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon zugestellt hast, dieses MM-Merkmal an. Das ist also ein nicht optisch wahrnehmbares, in der Karte eingebautes Merkmal. Das ist entweder eine induktive Geschichte, also mit Magnetspulen sozusagen, oder eben Infrarot. Mir hat mal jemand gesagt, es sei ein Infrarot-Barcode, aber das kann ich weder bestätigen noch beweisen. Aber ein Hologramm ist kein Sicherheitsmerkmal, ein Hologramm ist eine Sicherheitssimulation. Das wissen die auch, das so nebenbei.
Okay Roland, bis dann, ciao. Jetzt gibt es gleich ein kurzes Kurzinfo. Dann könnt ihr natürlich auch weiter anrufen.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Im Oderbruch müssen die Einwohner von etwa 40 weiteren Ortschaften evakuiert werden. Betroffen sind rund 15.000 Menschen. Grund ist ein neuer Deichrutsch bei Hohenwutzen. An der beschädigten Stelle sind Hubschrauber der Bundeswehr im Einsatz. Sie werfen Sandsecke ab, um einen Dammbruch doch noch zu verhindern. Gegenmaßnahmen. Nach dem Bombenanschlag in Jerusalem hat Palästinenser Präsident Arafat den Ausnahmezustand über die Autonomiegebiete verhängt. Er ordnete auch die Festnahme von Mitgliedern radikal islamischer Gruppen an. Inzwischen bekannte sich die Hamas zu dem Anschlag. Dabei wurden 14 Menschen getötet und mehr als 150 verletzt. Anklager, der mutmaßliche serbische Kriegsverbrecher Kovacevic, wurde heute erstmals dem UNO-Tribunal in den Haag vorgeführt. Bei der Anhörung beteuerte er seine Unschuld. Kovacevic war vor drei Wochen von einem SV-Kommando in Bosnien festgenommen worden. Er soll für die Vertreibung, Internierung und Ermordung von Muslims und Kroaten in der Prijedorregion mitverantwortlich sein. Angebot. Die Brandenburger Landesregierung will zum 1. Oktober 50 zusätzliche Lehrstellen in sogenannten Kammerberufen bereitstellen. Dabei handelt es sich unter anderem um Fachinformatiker und Kaufleuter für Bürokommunikation.
Wetter.
Nach 14 bis, nein, 17 bis 14 Grad morgen vereinzelt Schauer bis 24 Grad.
Verkehr.
Berlin-Spandau. Die Freibrücke ist wegen Bauarbeiten bis 6 Uhr in Richtung Charlottenburg auf einem Fahrstreifen eingeengt und Brandenburg-Frankfurt oder an der Grenze nach Polen gibt es aufgrund des Hochwassers an folgenden Stellen keine Abfertigung. An der Stadtbrücke Frankfurt oder Küstrin, Kiez und Hohenwutzen.
Das war Kerstin Kochmann.
Ja ich wollte die ganze Zeit mal was von der Woche. Mein Gott, ich dachte ich schaff das noch.
Kerstin Kochmann, kurz, kurz.
Fritz präsentiert Big Beats in Berlin.
Mittwoch, 20.
August in der Arena in Treppow.
Synthetisiert, katalysiert und explodiert durch Fritz.
Tritts!
Nine Inch Nails mit einem absolut wahnsinnig großartigen Stück, wie ich finde. Die perfekte Droga, auch so ein Soundtrack von Lost Highway. Ihr hört Chaos Radio Computer Club Berlin bei Fritz, es geht um EC-Karten und es gibt inzwischen auch viele Anfragen aus dem Chat hier. Ihr kann hier alles vorlesen und beantworten und auch noch telefonieren. Zumal der Chat immer so schnell runterläuft, da es so viele Leute sind, dass ich keine Zeit hab alles zu lesen.
Wir können auch mal zwei Informationen einstreuen, bevor wir weitere Hörereine nehmen und die betreffen sozusagen die Netzunsicherheit, die es da nämlich auch noch gibt. Also nur so als um mal eine Vorstellung zu geben, was es da schon alles an Missbrauch gegeben hat. Zum einen ist es so, dass die Automaten, wenn sie offline sind, also den Datensatz, den PIN-Code usw. sofort irgendwo hinschicken und dann eben auf das Akzeptiersignal der jeweiligen Bank warten, wo das Konto geführt wird. Und das ist unverschlüsselte Übertragungsmodus über Datex P, über sogenannte X25-Leitung, wo es wohl auch schon vorgekommen sein soll, dass dann dieses Akzeptiersignal, ja ja, ist in Ordnung, einfach gefälscht wurde, sodass die Automaten dann auch bei jeder PIN sozusagen das Geld ausgespuckt haben. Und warte mal, dann hatten wir noch diese andere Geschichte.
Ja, ich sollte mal kurz dazu sagen, dass viel von diesem Automatentrafik gerade im Osten über Satellitenschüssen abgewickelt wird, weil zu der Zeit, als die Westfilialen hier aufmachten, hat einfach noch nicht die Datenleitung dafür da war.
Eine andere Geschichte, die auch aufgetreten ist, von diesen 700 abgängigen Geldautomaten, wurden ich glaube 200 nicht oder ohne Sicherheitsmodul wieder aufgefunden. In diesem Sicherheitsmodul steckt die ganze Intelligenz drin, die den Pintest macht, d.h. man schickt da eine Pim rein, da kommt heraus, die ist gut oder die ist nicht gut und wenn man es geschickt anstellt, dieses Sicherheitsmodul ausbaut aus einem Geldautomaten, kann man natürlich einfach alle 10.000 Pins durchprobieren.
Sagen wir, ähm... Wenn man von diesen, ähm, dann ja, High-Tech-Kriminellen ausgeht, muss man sich doch fragen, wenn die so viel Ahnung von dem ganzen Kram haben, die wären doch auch sicher hochbezahlte Programmierer oder so.
Ja, das ist die Frage, was mir reizt.
Ich meine, abgesehen davon sind diese Sicherheitsmodule nicht nur in Geldautomaten drin, sondern jetzt neue Denksachen in Überweisungsautomaten, die bei vielen Banken aufgestellt werden, wo man halt dann Überweisungen direkt in der Bank tätigen kann. Das ist im Regelfall so ein OS-2-betriebener PC, wo halt so eine schwarze versiegelte Einstellkarte drin steckt und da ist halt diese Sicherheitskram drin. Also die haben dann extra Tastatur, die direkt von so einer PIN-Tastatur an der Seite, die dann direkt auf diese Karte geht.
Wer programmiert denn eigentlich, also was sind denn das für Firmen überhaupt, die sich um diesen ganzen Kram kümmern? Also das sind doch ganz normale Leute, die diese Sicherheitsgeschichten programmieren müssen, die mit der Hardware umgehen und so. Da ist doch auch eine riesen Sicherheitslücke. Das sind ja nicht nur zwei Leute auf der ganzen Welt.
Na ja, also sie geben sich da schon ein bisschen Mühe. Was verdient man denn da? Meistens beauftragen sie halt irgendwie solche Behörden wie IBM, wo man halt sicher sein kann, dass die irgendwie ihre Programmiererabschottung schon irgendwie einigermaßen geregelt bekommen und die halt auch in der Lage sind mit so großen Systemen umzugehen. Und natürlich gehen da auch Leute abgängig. Ich meine, wenn man da irgendwie 5000 Mark im Monat bei IBM verdient und dann kommt irgendwie irgendjemand aus was weiß ich, Singapur an und bietet einem mal 5 Millionen auf den Schlacht dafür, dass man irgendwie diese die Teil verrät.
Gut, wir werden weiter telefonieren, das sind nämlich hier nicht, aber ansonsten sind da ein Menge Hörer dran. Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ja, ich wollte mal fragen, ich hab noch ein Atari Portfolio.
Ich hab noch nicht so lange zugehört, was hat denn das mit den Ziffern auf sich?
Ach, wir wollten doch von jedem Hörer den ersten Pin deiner EC-Karte wissen.
Die erste Ziffer deiner EC-Karte.
Muss ich erstmal nachschauen?
Was?
Ich darf das doch gar nicht aufschreiben.
Bitte?
Schon wieder einer dagegen, die irgendwie...
Hast du deine Pin irgendwo notiert?
Ach so, dann muss ich erstmal überlegen.
Aber was war mit deiner Pin?
Das ist doch die 3.
Eine 3?
So und jetzt, deine Frage?
Ja, also ich hab noch ein altes Atari Portfolio und da wollte ich mal fragen, ob es da überhaupt noch Software für gibt und speziell vielleicht eine Spack-Software, weil man da drüber ja normalerweise mit dem Telefon, das braucht man ja einfach nur ranzuhalten, dann wählt er automatisch die Adresse über den Automat.
Sag mal Johnny, diese Tasse mit dem K hier, ist das die Catapult-Taste?
Ja, Martin, du bist beim völlig falschen Thema.
Oh, welches Thema ist denn heute dran?
EC-Karten. Nichts, die konfiguriere ich mein Computer.
Guck mal, das ist so ein bisschen wie im Internet. Erst mal eine halbe Stunde zugucken oder zuhören und dann reden.
Hast du EC-Karten, könnte ich euch auch mal was sagen.
Ja, ach Martin, nö, da hören wir erstmal ein bisschen zu. Martin, hast du einen Internetzugang? Na ja, man, da gibt es da über ein Portfolio garantiert mehr, als wir dir hier erzählen können. Na ja, nur, also.
Der Chaos Computer Club Berlin ist ja auch nicht so groß, als ich da bin. Wir sind ja Chaos Computer Club, wir sind nicht für deine Soundbuster-Karte zuständig.
Wenn die nichts haben, dann haben wir auch nichts. Martin, ich nehme mal den nächsten Hörer, ja?
Und bei mir ist was sehr Interessantes passiert mit einem EC-Automaten in...
Du musst erstmal dein Radio leiser machen, Friedrich. Sonst pfeift's. Ist zwar auch schön, aber dann hören wir dich nicht so. Was war denn das für Musik gerade?
Das war das Dreizwillinge-Jingle.
Das Dreizwillinge-Jingle?
Bist du einer von den beiden oder bist du alle drei?
Ich bin einer von den dreien, also einer von ihnen.
Alles klar.
Okay, EC Automaten.
Ja und zwar in Trenzlau an der Tankstelle. Und ich wollte Geld abheben, 150 Mark. Und irgendwie hat es aber nicht so geklappt. Ich weiß nicht warum, also es kann sein, dass ich kein 150 Mark mehr auf dem Konto hatte. Aber es ist was passiert, was ich nun gar nicht erwartet hätte. Die Karte hat den Automaten beheizen. Und das will Peter noch was sagen.
Na, wegen der Karte.
Also es war ein Prenzlau. Also Verkehrsbedingungen, die Verkehrsbedingungen waren wirklich schlecht.
Also es war mitten im Stau eigentlich.
Kann man mal die Katerpulttaste bitte?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nee, ihr seid nicht lustig. Ihr seid nicht lustig.
Ihr seid nicht lustig.
Wir lassen ja jeden Scheiß hier laufen, aber es muss schon lustig sein. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist da? Ja, hi, wer bist denn du?
Ahja, ging direkt durch.
Direkt durch, so? Wie mit der Information?
Ja, nee, das ist der Andreas, aber ich rufe aus Dresden an, deswegen wundert es mich jetzt.
Achso, wie muss man aus Dresden noch vorher woanders anrufen?
Nee, aber das ging das Fenster mal über so eine Leine und dann wurde man dann irgendwann zugeschaltet.
Ja, das hier ist aber Chaosradio, das geht direkt. Was sind deine erste Ziffer von der PIN?
Von der neuen oder von der alten?
Beide.
Die alte ist die 1 und die neue die 3.
Guck mal, bei den neueren sind mehr 3.
Das ist aber klar, das sind alle, aber unter 5. Weil die Zahlen unter 5 ja sozusagen doppelt so häufig wie die ersten.
Ja, es gibt bisher nur eine.
Aber er hatte eine Frage.
Über 5, ja du hast aber eine Frage, sorry.
Nee, Frage eigentlich nicht, es ging doch um eine andere PIN Nummer und zwar von meiner Freundin. Die hat eine 1 drin und dann eine Zahl doppelt und beide unter 5.
Ja, das kommt vor, aber es kommt eben nicht vor, oder soll angeblich nicht vorkommen, dass alle 4 Ziffern gleich sind.
Aber immerhin, da weiß man ja schon eine Menge, es kommt eine 1 drin vor und 2 doppelt und sie sind unter 5. So, liebe Hörer am Radio, wer jetzt als erstes anruft und die PIN von Andreas Freundin... Es geht bei dieser Frage nach der ersten Ziffer natürlich nicht darum, dass wir jetzt irgendwie rumrechnen, sondern es geht wirklich um so eine Statistik und die ist bis jetzt schon sehr interessant. Also mit einer Ausnahme alle nicht höher als 5.
Warte mal, ich habe hier noch einen schönen Satz aus dem Gutachten, den kann man ja noch mal einfügen. Es muss auch als konstruktiver Mängel gewertet werden, dass immer noch Geldautomaten mit Touchscreen Tastatur im Einsatz sind, wie zum Beispiel bei der Citibank. Bei diesen Automaten wird auf einem Bildschirm des Tastenfelds gezeigt, dass durch Berühren der Schaltflächen bedient wird. Naturgemäß drückt der Bediener besonders stark auf, weil die auf dem Bildschirm dargestellten Tasten keinen Hub haben. Jeder alleine kann sich vorstellen, dass bei einer vorher gereinigten Bildschirmoberfläche eine Pin-Eingabe aufgrund der Hautfettspuren deutlich zu erkennen ist. Spezialisten erkennen an dem Verfettungsgefälle sogar die Zifferanfolge. So kann ein Kriminal schnell eine Pin ermitteln.
Verfettungsgefälle ist ein super tolles Wort.
Das merken wir uns jetzt alle.
Henning, hi.
Grüßt euch. Ich finde das ja irgendwie ganz witzig, wie viele Pins ihr schon so gesammelt habt. Zweimal bloß das erste Viertel. Aber da wusste einer die Pinn von einer Freundin offensichtlich. Und dann möglichst noch vor dem Nachbarn.
Wenn die sich mal streiten meinst du? Wenn die sich mal streiten.
Nö, nicht wenn die sich mal streiten, sondern wir haben jetzt schon eine ganz schöne Datensammlung zusammengestellt.
Jetzt red mal nicht drum rum, was ist denn deine erste?
Du hast auf den Zehntel gebracht, ne? Also schon zehnmal bessere Chancen haben, den Rest auch noch rauszufinden.
Na ja.
Eigentlich wollen wir natürlich damit reich werden. Wir sammeln alle Pins und geben deine CD herum raus.
Was wolltest du eigentlich?
Also die erste Ziffer von einer Pin-Nummer von jemandem, von dem wir weder den Namen noch irgendwas anderes haben, nützt uns sehr herzlich wenig. Was ist denn deine erste Ziffer?
Ich hätt halt eine Stimme von jemandem irgendwie so. Ich hab neulich zum Beispiel eine Kommilitonin getroffen, bei euch gehört. Ja und da einen Vornamen dazu. Da hätt ich das jetzt sofort rausgefunden, wer das ist. Und jetzt, wenn ich meine sagen würde, irgendwie so. Aber der Beweis ist doch eigentlich, ihr bemüht euch doch jetzt so anzuprangern, was da die Fehler sind. Um die Fehler abzubauen, um das System sicherer zu machen.
Nein, sondern es geht...
Sonst bräuchte ich da doch nicht dagegen wettern, dass es so viele Einzige gibt. Und wenn dann halt dabei rauskommt, dass etliche Leute, zum Beispiel der eben von seiner Freundin die PIN wusste, dann wundert mich doch überhaupt nicht, warum das System so unsicher ist.
Ja, Moment, aber wir sind ja nicht in erster Linie hier, um euch zu erzählen, so und so unsicher ist das und so und so das und das müsste man machen, um es sicherer zu machen. Sondern es geht im Kern um was anderes. Es geht im Kern immer noch um diese Haftungsfrage, über die wir hier eigentlich reden. Nämlich die Frage, wer muss wem was beweisen. Und das technische Sicherheit eine Illusion ist. Das ist eigentlich das, was sozusagen da als Glaube bei uns wieder dahinter steckt. Deswegen gehen wir da so ein bisschen in die Details.
Ja, ich arbeite in der Bank.
Ja und?
Ich hab neulich mal so eine Spüle der Sache gehabt, eine Kundin ist verstorben. Drei Tage später wird ihr Konto abgeräumt. Und da war es leer. Das war eine Rentnerin. Erben haben sich nicht gemeldet. An sich wohl auch nicht melden, denn das Konto ist dadurch überzogen worden. Weil sie natürlich noch ein Dispo da hatte. Und jetzt eine Banane irgendwie so.
Und was sollen wir dazu sagen?
Was soll man dazu sagen? Das Problem ist ganz einfach diesen verdammten Umschlag irgendwo rumliegen zu lassen. Um gar nicht erst in die Bedrohliche kommen zu müssen.
Ich meine, die Frau ist ja jetzt tot.
Sie kann ja selber nicht haften. Die hat ihre Nummer da sehr alt ist, und sie vielleicht Nummer nicht marken kann irgendwo aufgeschrieben. Und gehen wir mal davon aus, dass irgendjemand aus der Familie das gefunden hat, das Konto bis zum Disporand geplündert hat. Und wer haftet jetzt? Eure Versicherung, also die der Bank. Ich hab dich auch nicht gefragt. Also die Versicherung der Bank haftet.
Die Versicherung der Bank. Wenn sie es dann versichert hat, dann ist immer die Frage, ob das gemacht wird. Oder ob die Händler sagen, wir wollen nicht den Aufwand betreiben, wir übernehmen das auf unsere Kappe. Da gibt es eben die beiden Möglichkeiten. Also ich finde das schon irgendwie so bedenklich. Und ich hab da vor Jahren schon Kunden gehabt, gerade so wo diese Diskussion war. Ihr habt das ja auch recht schön ganz kurz mit angerissen. So vor 10 Jahren, Ratgeber Technik, gibt es wirklich den Kriminellen da noch Rat, irgendwie so. Und halt eben nicht so eine ganz tolle Berichterstattung gemacht hat. Und weil man dann halt eben auch Jahre später noch irgendwo eine EC-Karte in der Hand hat, oder eine Kundenkarte oder irgendwie so. Und da steht eine PIN drauf, also wenn da vier Ziffern draufstehen. Ja und dann auch noch zugegeben, dass dies das gewesen ist.
Ja aber ein Problem hab ich mit deiner Aussage, weil du gehst ja davon aus, dass dadurch, dass zum Beispiel ARD-Radgeber Technik jetzt Informationen öffentlich gemacht hat, dass dadurch sozusagen Kriminelle es einfacher gemacht wurde, da irgendwie zu agieren. Und das ist insofern, Entschuldigung, muss ich nach meinem Glauben sagen, Quatsch. Weil ein Sicherheitssystem, das darauf beruht, dass man Sachen geheim hält, ist sowieso Quatsch. Das ist das, was man in der Branche Security by Obscurity nennt. Und das Gegenteil ist mittlerweile eigentlich sozusagen in der Fachwelt anerkannt, nämlich dass ein System dann sicherst, wenn alle wissen können, wie es funktioniert. Und trotzdem ist es nicht knackbar. Weil einfach, wenn die Bank einfach, das ist nicht klar, dass die Banken das gern unter den Teppich halten.
Ich finde auch ehrlich gesagt, den Schluss, den du ziehst, Henning, den finde ich echt sehr merkwürdig. Wenn du jetzt diese Geschichte erzählst von einer verstorbenen Frau und dann sagst, da muss man sich Gedanken drum machen, wie die Leute mit ihren PIN-Nummern umgehen? Nee, da muss man sich Gedanken drum machen, wie die Banken mit unserem Geld umgehen. Also es ist doch ein Bankproblem, wenn die so eine Sicherung über eine vierstellige Zahl machen, nur, dann müssen sich die Banken Gedanken machen.
Und wenn sie sich um die Menschen so wenig kümmern, dass die ein paar mal sterben wollen.
Ich meine das zweischneidig, wir werden nie zu einer Aussage kommen. Ich kann sie für mich nicht kommen, ihr schafft das ja auch nicht.
Zu einer Aussage?
Zu einer endgültigen Aussage, so und so muss es sein oder irgendwie so oder so.
Wir haben eine Vision, Mann.
Natürlich, die hab ich auch, logisch.
Na ja, wir können ja das schon sagen.
Ich bin wieder wie mein Bankschütze auf dem Dorf und dann ist halt eben gut. Da kann nichts dazwischen kommen.
Nee, ich find das schon ganz praktisch, wenn ich auch Nachts und für Geld abholen kann. Das find ich schon ganz okay.
Der guckt mir ins Auge, guckt wie meine Iris aussieht.
Wir glauben den Automaten.
Genau, also ich glaube wir können davon ausgehen, dass jede technische Einrichtung, auch die, die dir ins Auge guckt, überlistet werden kann. Das eigentliche Problem ist gar nicht die Technik, sondern das Problem ist der Glaube an die Technik und das Problem ist die Haftung. Dass nämlich der Kunde beweisen muss, dass er nicht seine PIN aufgeschrieben hat, was ja wohl völlig widersinnig ist. Bei Kreditkarten funktioniert das ja auch so, dass die Kreditkartengesellschaft das Haftungsrisiko übernimmt. Übrigens kann es dem Kunden gar nicht zugemutet werden, dass er sich auskennt, wie dann die Sicherheit bei dem Verfahren ist. Er kann das ja gar nicht einschätzen.
Bei Kreditkarten ist ja der Missbrauch des...
Und dann kannst du es mit deiner Moral verantworten, bei einer Bank zu erwarten?
Ich hab die Türen nicht. Henning, ich sag schon mal danke. Oh, Henning muss morgen früh raus wieder. Hier gab es übrigens jemanden im Chat, der behauptet, dass seine 96er EC-Karte vier gleiche Ziffern gehabt hätte. Hat aber jetzt eine neue und da ist es nicht mehr so. Und fragt sich, ob es vielleicht bei Neuen jetzt nicht mehr so ist.
Kannst du denen mal eine E-Mail notieren bitte?
Ja, ich schreib's nicht. Kai, wenn du uns auch hörst, musst du uns ja hören scheinbar, schick mal eine E-Mail an chaos.orbe.de bitte. Das interessiert hier Leute. So, die Leitungen sind voll. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ich hab eine Frage, es gibt zurück auf eine Panoramasendung, so circa vor anderthalb Jahren. Da war es so, die hatten, ich glaube es war ein Zip-Bank-Automat, einfach eine Karte reingesteckt, eine Fantasienummer eingegeben und der hat Geld gegeben.
Ja, es gab einen Fall bei der Citibank, wo ich glaube über mehrere Wochen sogar die Automaten, alle überhaupt keine Pins überprüft haben. Das haben die dann nochmal nachgestellt.
Nee, also da gab es irgendwie, da gab es eine definitive Information, woran es lag. Es gab nur Spekulation, ne? Dass die die PIN-Prüfung ausgeschaltet haben, bei allen Automaten, weil sie technische Probleme hatten. Also irgendwie hatten sie wohl Sprech mit ihren Karten oder irgendwie sowas und haben deswegen irgendwie für mehrere Wochen die PIN-Prüfung komplett ausgeschaltet gehabt. Das ist oft mal bei der Sparkasse irgendwie unvollteilbar passiert worden.
Achso, meine PIN ist nun für zwei.
Also da braucht man sich nun wirklich keine Sorgen drum machen, wenn man hier anruft und die erste Ziffer seiner PIN sagt. Es ist relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass wir...
Relativ.
Das ist relativ unwahrscheinlich. Wir haben hier nämlich so ein Computerprogramm laufen und am Ende der Sendung gehen wir dann alle vollständig in den PIN-Nummern durch. Wir haben die Stimmenanalyse gemacht und dann mit der ersten Ziffer...
Wieso? Wir haben doch die STN-Nummern gesehen.
Am tollsten sind anonyme E-Mails aus T-Online, wo noch vorne die Telefonnummer steht. Man kriegt ja als Fritz-Moderator interessante E-Mails. Viele, viele nette, aber auch viele, viele komplett bescheuerte. Und die schönsten sind eigentlich also die beklopptesten E-Mails, die man kriegt, sind die, die nur pöbeln und dann so richtig schön ausfallend werden, in der Hoffnung, dass man ja nicht weiß, wer die sind. Und dann aber noch hinten vorne irgendwie so die Telefonnummer da hat, wo man dann doch immer so ein bisschen, wo ich die Hand am Telefonhörer hab und denke... Das schimpfst du die Nacht, wenn du eine schlechte Laune hast.
So eine Geschichte, dass die PIN überhaupt nicht geprüft wurde, gab es hier auch mal in Berlin von August bis Mitte Oktober 1995. Da haben die Berliner Sparkassen Geldautomaten auch die PIN einfach nicht überprüft und einfach Geld ausgegeben.
Schönes übrigens, wenn im Chat irgendjemand... Bekloppte gibt es ja überall, so natürlich auch im Internet und zwar massig. Wenn im Chat jemand einfach über Ficken schreibt, Fragezeichen und als Antwort gleich darauf, Nö, komm. So, machen wir weiter hier, die Leitungen voll, ja. Hi, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio. Fabian, was ist deine erste Ziffer?
Ich hab keinen, ich bin erst 14. Ja, eine ganz kurze Frage nur und zwar, was ist sicherer? Also wobei kann man schneller beschweren beim Banküberfall oder beim Flündern von so einem EC-Automaten?
Moment, was meint er mit sicherer? Sicherer aus der Sicht des Angreifers oder aus der Sicht des Abwehrers?
Äh, des Angreifers.
Na, dann würde ich sagen...
Banküberfall ist eine schlechte Wahl.
Ja, Banküberfall ist irgendwie...
Das lohnt sich auch nicht.
Vor allem kriegst du das Geld dann mit so roten Päckchen, die dir dann in der Plastiktüte explodieren und dann irgendwie hast du irgendwie rote Farbe überall, das ist echt lästig.
Fünf Jahre kriegst du da mindestens.
Das ist übrigens auch illegal.
Ja, danke. Also ich ziehe gerade an, das ist auch illegal.
Zum Glück hat er mich nicht gefragt, ob das nicht egal ist, weil er mit 14 aber nicht haftbar ist.
Ja, ich fahre hier mit so einer alten Dame durch die Gegend und die will Geld abheben. Du stell dir mal vor, da hat die so ein Zettel in der Hand, da ist die ganze Pinnentropf gewesen.
Bist du ein Taxifahrer? Das ist natürlich, wir haben es vorhin ja auch schon gehört, ich finde das völlig verständlich, dass ältere Leute sich das aufschreiben. Also ich meine...
Das Gaudi, das war ja noch, die kam nicht mal rein in die Bank. Die hat dich dann geschickt.
Und dann hast du ihr geholfen.
Und die Pinnentropfen fingen übrigens mit einer 3 an.
Danke schön.
Ja, aber da kann man auch froh sein, wenn man an einen ehrlichen Taxifahrer gerät, oder?
Ja, vor allem, da merkt sich die Zahl nicht. Ich habe die anderen drei vergessen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch alles sehr hypothetisch und es geht ja wirklich darum, ein bisschen zu erklären, wie sowas funktioniert. Dynamizier 1. Der Preis für den witzigsten Namen im Chat geht heute übrigens an denjenigen oder diejenige, die sich hier Ratgebertechnik nennt. Man muss den Namen von dem jungen Mann, der hier diese Mod-Files macht, nochmal sagen und vielleicht für alle anderen, die nicht wissen, was Mod-Files sind, erklären. Das ist hier das Musik, die jemand zu Hause am Computer, am Amiga kreiert.
An einem PC mit Fast Tracker.
Die macht er zu Hause und wir haben eine CD davon gemacht und wer die haben will, kann uns 30 mal schicken. Homemade, Junge, melde dich bei GEMA an und kriegst du Geld. So, wer ist jetzt dran, der macht weiter. Die Hörer. Ach, die Hörer.
Die Hörer, hallo. Thorsten, gut durchgehalten.
Thorsten, was ist deine erste Ziffer?
Bei der neuen ist es eine 1. Bei der alten vor drei Jahren auch eine 1. Das war interessant.
Dann nimm mal zwei 1.
Ja, ich hab mich schon gewundert, aber langsam ist es logisch, dass da so viele 1 kommen. Ich hab mir gesagt, jede vierte ist eine 1 oder so. Ich hab aber eigentlich ein ganz anderes Problem mit den Karten. Und zwar weniger, dass einer von mir Geld abhebt und dass unter bestimmten Bedingungen ich selber kein Geld kriege. Und was mir da ganz spontan aufgefallen ist, dass es immer wenn ich in Skandinavien war, dass ich dann mit meiner Karte in Deutschland kein Geld mehr abheben kann. Das dauerte ungefähr eine Woche und dann geht sie wieder. Das ist also, also die Karte vor drei Jahren war ich in Schweden. Da ist mir das erste Mal aufgefallen, dass ich dann wieder bei der Frühe war, dass das nicht funktionierte. Und ich hab jetzt auch die Bank gewechselt und somit auch eine neue Karte. Und das sehr phänomenische ist, dass wir dieses Jahr auch wieder aufgetreten sind.
Hast du viel damit in Schweden abgehoben?
In Schweden, ja klar. Also kann in Schweden überall, das ist kein Problem gewesen. Aber dann zurückkommen, ging jetzt nicht mehr. Auf der Insel Rügen.
Sieben Tage oder so?
Also ungefähr eine Woche. Das erste Mal war wirklich sieben Tage, genau. Und diesmal war es drei, fünf Tage oder so.
Na ja, es gibt ja bei EC-Karten ein Limit. Also man kann in einer Woche nur eine bestimmte Menge abheben. Und jetzt weiß ich leider nicht genau, wie das ist, wenn man im Ausland abgehoben hat. Aber ich denke, das kann damit zusammenhängen, dass halt im Ausland der Check nicht funktioniert hat. Und als du wieder gekommen bist, haben sie festgestellt, du hast dein Wochenlimit überschritten. Du musstest deshalb erst mal eine Woche warten.
Und noch ein Wochenlimit, ja?
Es gibt ein Tageslimit und ein Wochenlimit, ja.
Beziehungsweise, das ist der sogenannte Typ für das Limit.
Wo liegt das Wochenlimit?
Das steht auf deiner Karte drauf.
Das ist je nachdem, wie du eingeschätzt wirst.
Also von der Konterdeckung her ist das halt kein Thema gewesen.
Das kann aber sein, dass Sie am Ausland sozusagen keine Möglichkeit haben, eben weil Sie kein Online haben, zu überprüfen, ob das, was auf deinem Magnetstreifen drauf steht, also das, was sozusagen vorgibt, der Zyklus dein Limit zu sein, ob das auch wirklich stimmt. Und deswegen gehen Sie womöglich auf Nummer sicher, sagen, naja, wir wissen nicht, was da im Ausland irgendwie war. Und deswegen warten wir jetzt sozusagen, bis der nächste Zyklus anläuft, weil da wissen wir, wie viel Limit wir haben, wenn du dann wieder in Deutschland bist.
Oder es gibt eine Drift zwischen den Zyklen, dass die Zykluszahl in Schweden anders vorangesetzt wird als in Deutschland.
Oder es wird einfach im Ausland gar nicht überprüft, weil der Automat feststellt, ist eine fremde Währung, komme ich nicht mit klar, fasse ich mal nicht an.
Kann man das aber irgendwie ändern?
Das kann die Bank ändern, ja.
Das kann dich ein bisschen unbefriedigen, wenn du aus dem Urlaub kommst und kein Geld kriegst.
Aber ich hab mir das aufgeschrieben, ich hab eine Idee, wo ich da nochmal nachfahren kann, ist eine gute Frage.
Dann ist mir wirklich das nur, wenn Skandinavien passiert, in Österreich, wenn ich zurückkomme, überhaupt nicht. Oft auch in Spanien auch nicht. Also es ist in allen skandinavischen Ländern passiert.
Haben vielleicht andere Hörer noch ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht?
Ich hab das vor, nicht mehr mitzukommen. Wenn man jetzt die Karten, die PIN eingibt, fragt der Automat dann einem Bankrechner nach, ob die PIN stimmt oder rechnet er das selber aus?
Nein, er rechnet das eigentlich selber aus, fragt aber trotzdem noch bei der Bank, ob z.B. dein Konto dann auch gedeckt ist.
Weil mir ist das nämlich auch schon mal so gelegentlich passiert, ich bin nicht mehr bei der Sparkasse, aber wenn ich da Geld abheben will, dass dann so gelingt, dass die Meldung kommt, keine Verbindung zum Bankrechner oder so.
Und dann gibt er dir kein Geld?
Nein, das ist ja das Problem, ja. Dann gibt er ihm kein Geld und die netten Leute von der Bank, dann von der Sparkasse ja versuchen sie es wieder. Dann steht er stundenlang da und ist natürlich unbefriedigt.
Das sind Geräte, die nur online sind und die, wenn deine Heimbank über das X25-Netz nicht erreichbar ist, dann einfach nichts auszahlen. Das ist auch sehr verbreit, ich hab das auch öfter gehabt.
Aber ich hab jetzt mal eine ganz direkte Frage zu diesem komischen Schlüssel, um den es immer geht, zur Berechnung. Im Prinzip ist ja klar, aus welchen Ziffern, also Kontonummer und so weiter und so fort, errechnet er mittels des Schlüssels die PIN.
Richtig.
Kann man jetzt, also rein theoretisch müsste man das auch rückwärts berechnen können.
Nein, kannst du nicht, weil der DES ist zwar rezipro, das heißt, du kannst das, was du sozusagen als Ergebnis des Rechenprozess hast, auch wieder, wenn du den geheimen Schlüssel hast, kannst du auch wieder das Urspiel nicht errechnen. Du kannst aber nicht, wenn du beides hast zum Beispiel, also wenn du den PIN hast und den Datensatz hast, den Schlüssel ausrechnen. Das geht nicht. Na, das ist eine sogenannte mathematische Falltürfunktion. Wenn du da einmal reinfällst, kommst du nicht wieder nach oben.
Also, ich bin eigentlich nur darauf, ihr habt vorhin irgendwas mit diesem Adler da gefragt oder so, ne? Wie kann ich mich nämlich erinnern, also als ich noch Schüler war, so ans Lütte, da war ich in so einem Mathematikclub und wir hatten da eine, die hat die unmöglichsten Gleichungen, aber nie durch ein Nachgleichungssystem gelöst, sondern immer nur nach so einem Abschätzverfahren. Die hat wirklich die Unmöglichkeit und unnötig schnell eigentlich rauszukommen, wie die Lösungen von Gleichungen sind. Sie hat immer so Eckwerte berechnet und hat dann gesehen, ob es größer oder kleiner wird wie die Folge. Dann hat sie das irgendwie abgeschätzt. Sie hat für meine Verhältnisse damals ziemlich komplizierte Gleichungssysteme auf die Art und Weise gelöst.
Naja, es ist immer eine Frage, wie begabt man dafür ist. Dann kann man das teilweise auch im Kopf lösen bzw. bekommt ein Gefühl dafür, wie die Gleichung funktioniert. Aber das hilft dann nicht wirklich weiter.
Aber deswegen wäre die Idee gewesen, dieses Emotiv zurückzurechnen. Das ist ja letztendlich mehr oder weniger nicht so einfach.
Da sitzen tausende Mathematiker seit 30 Jahren dran, das zu probieren. Bisher hat es noch keiner geschafft. Es ist natürlich theoretisch denkbar, dass es da so einen Weg gibt und dass da jemand kommt und die entsprechende Mathematik parat hat. Aber das, was du da gesehen hast, ist eher so eine Art mathematische Begabung. Das ist sehr verbreitet bei Leuten, die dann auch tatsächlich Mathematik studieren, dass man einfach in der Gleichung ansieht, wie sie funktioniert. Und wenn man das halt kann, ist es ein echter Vorteil. Wenn man das nicht kann, sollte man das Mathesstudieren bleiben lassen.
Weil ihr habt ja vorhin irgendwie gesagt, dass im Grunde diese zwei Schlüssel, die da gehen, dieser allgemeine und der spezielle, dass es da letztendlich nur 1 zu 150 verschiedene Möglichkeiten gibt.
Na, das hängt eben noch mit dieser Hex zu...
Das sind aber Möglichkeiten für die PIN und nicht für den Key.
Ach so, das sind die 2. Stufe.
Die PIN ist das, was du eingibst, und der Key ist, dass der Geheimschlüssel da drin steckt. Und der ist 56 Bit lang. Und der wird auch durch diesen anderen Schlüssel halt nicht wirklich bekannter.
Ja, das hab ich am Anfang mal Auto mitgekriegt, mit dem Schlüssel und dem Berechnungen. Und der Wohnung dann auf diese, also keine 0 und die 1, wenn das alles gut ist. Deswegen ist mir jetzt auch klar, warum das immer mit der 1 beginnt. Das ist nicht immer, aber fast immer.
Auf jeden Fall haben wir das mit dieser Statistik, mit der Kleinen hier auch zumindest annähernd, auch bestätigt. Thorsten war das, ne? Okay, danke erstmal. Bis dann.
Und weiter geht's.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Niemand mehr. Zu spät reagiert.
Vielleicht können wir dann noch ein bisschen auf den letzten Punkt weiteratmen.
Ich hab massig Hörer noch hier.
Du hast massig Hörer?
Willst du oder nicht?
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Ist euch mal aufgefallen, eine Frau hat heute angerufen.
Ja, ich bin keine Frau, ne?
Nee, aber du kannst ja deine Stimme verstellen. Nein, es geht ja einfach nur darum, dass das doch immer noch so ein super Männerthema ist, so Technik und so.
Und der erste Ziffer, deiner PIN?
Ach so, ja, die ersten noch mal, ne, das sind zwei.
Und deine Fragen?
Ja.
Ich hab vorhin gefragt, hat der iterativen Analysis nach Adler.
Ja, das ist eine wiederholende Grenzwertbetrachtung.
Eine wiederholende Grenzwertbetrachtung.
Und überhaupt Grenzwertberechnung.
Analysis für Grenzwertberechnung. Hab ich das in Erinnerung.
Woher weißt du das? Na ja, so in Informatik bin ich ein bisschen angesiedelt.
Nützt du das als was, Jungs?
Hast du vielleicht eine Referenz? Also weißt du in welchem Buch das erwähnt wird? Also kennst du konkret den Namen iterative Analyse nach Adler oder ist das jetzt bloß?
Nee, also iterativ weiß ich nun auch vom Programmieren her, was das ist.
Ja, so weit sind wir auch schon gekommen. Also was iterativ und Analyse ist, wissen wir. Aber wie das Verfahren nach Adler aussieht, das interessiert uns konkret.
Ja, aber ich hab mal geguckt, also Adler hab ich jetzt gar nicht gefunden.
Ich hab mich auch nicht gefunden.
Es kann sein, dass sie den irgendwie ausradiert haben, weil da irgendwie...
Aber wir können uns ja auf jeden Fall mal deine Adresse aufschreiben. Vielleicht bist du ja am nächsten dran.
Ich war jetzt nicht über den Sender.
Nee, du bleibst gleich einfach am Telefon und wir schreiben dann deine Adresse auf. Ist aber noch nicht sicher, ob du gewonnen hast. Also wenn niemand Besseres kommt, dann kriegst du...
Wir wollen immer noch den Pool-Schlüssel.
Den hab ich leider nicht.
Wenn es keine bessere Erklärung gibt, dann bist du der Gewinner.
Bis gleich.
So, jetzt spielen wir hier noch ein Mod-File. Ich hab eins mit 13 Minuten und noch was hab ich nicht. Ich hab das hier. Oder wolltest du?
Na ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, in welcher Qualität ich das hier rüberbringe. Aber wir können es ja einfach mal probieren.
Lass mal hören.
Und lassen mal die schwarze Sonne... Lassen wir jetzt mal aufsteigen.
Oder? Kommt doch jetzt von beiden Kanälen.
Ach, das war das Falsche.
Jetzt haben wir doch das, was wir das letzte Mal gespielt haben.
Ja, ja, ich glaube ich spiel mal lieber das Richtige. Das andere hatten wir nämlich schon beim vorletzten Mal.
Mal gucken, ob der Rechner hält. Chaos Radio Computer Club Berlin bei Fritz. Das geht um EC-Karten, um PIN-Codes, um Sicherheit und um Haftung. Ich finde in der letzten halben Stunde sollten wir noch mal ein bisschen über Haftung reden. Jetzt machen wir noch eine kurze Telefonrunde, dann gibt es ein bisschen Musik und das Fritz-Kurz-Info und dann haben wir noch bis 1 Uhr Zeit die iterative Analyse nach Adler zu erklären. Wenn das noch jemand weiß, Dirk ist im Rennen und kriegt das Microsoft-Attacks-T-Shirt, wenn nicht noch jemand anders kommt, der eine bessere Erklärung für die iterative Analyse nach Adler hat. Oder den Pool-Schlüssel. Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ah, ich wollte bloß sagen, dass mein erster PIN 9 ist.
9?
Hey, hey, ein Ausweis.
Mehr nicht?
Nee, mehr nicht.
Du hast uns die Statistik versorgt.
Wahrscheinlich gelogen.
Genau, gezielte Desinformationen.
Das war das Problem, ihr hättet einfach alle anrufen müssen und sagen sollen, 9.
Nein, Johnny macht die nicht wahnsinnig.
Na ja, dann wäre doch aber unsere Statistik völlig voll.
Johnny, du verfällst was, kannst du mal den Niesenhörer nehmen.
Ja, hallo, wer ist denn da? Jana? Okay, was ist denn deine erste Ziffer? 6? Hat man noch gar nicht?
Hat man noch nicht?
Aha, stimmt.
Und die 7 bis jetzt auch noch gar nicht?
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich schon mal sagen, dass ich heute Vertrauen habe.
Bitte?
Ich hab heute Vertrauen zu EC-Karten und PINs und ja, Heimlummern.
Warum?
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich noch keine schlechten Erfahrungen gemacht hab.
Was heißt Vertrauen? Also du machst dir da überhaupt keine Sorgen? Ich mach mir ehrlich gesagt auch keine Sorgen. Ich find's trotzdem ganz wichtig zu wissen, wie das alles funktioniert und...
Ja, das weiß ich.
worauf ich achten muss. Woher weißt du das genau?
Na, weil ich gut bei der Bank arbeite.
Ach du machst jetzt so ein bisschen Bankwerbung, sozusagen.
Wahrscheinlich hängt das Ding auch vom Vertrauen, weil also bei uns ist es jedenfalls, also sagen wir mal aus meiner Erfahrung, war das bisher so, dass 90 Prozent der Leute, wo was passiert ist, leider auch ihre Geheimnisse aufgeschrieben haben.
Dass die was? Die hatten es aufgeschrieben? Ja gut, aber das kann man ja nicht vermeiden. Also dazu kannst du ja Leute nicht zwingen, dass sie das nicht tun.
Ja, das ist das Dumme an der ganzen Geschichte. Weil jemand, also ich sag mal so, also ich hab zum Beispiel gute Zahlen, die gucken mir die Zahlen immer an, aber Leute, die das nicht können, wo das nicht so ist, die haben natürlich wirklich, ja, Schwierigkeiten. Obwohl ich immer noch der Meinung bin, dass man auch verschiedene Sachen dann machen kann, dass das eben nicht offensichtlich ist.
Andererseits darf man natürlich die restlichen 10 Prozent, die sich ihre EC-Karte nicht aufschreiben und trotzdem Verlust haben, nicht mit den 90 Prozent in einen Topf werfen.
Nee, um Gottes Willen.
Das passiert aber jetzt ja am Anfang.
Ja, ich hab eben hier Fälle auf dem Tisch, wo irgendwelche Leute, die nicht sonderlich viel Geld verdienen, für die sind ein paar tausend Mark einfach mal richtig viel Kohle und eventuell richtig die Existenz. Und ich weiß ja nicht, in welchem Bereich der Bank du arbeitest, aber ich weiß, dass solche Fälle auch einfach bei jeder Bank mal vorkommen. Und eben nicht kuhlang geregelt werden und dann irgendwelche Leute da eben. Und insofern kann ich dein Vertrauen da irgendwie ein bisschen schlecht gegenüberstellen, weißt du, weil jede Existenz ist eine zu viel.
Ja, sicher, ich erinnere mich insofern auch immer, weil gerade wenn man als Kundenberater da sitzt, man das auch einschätzen kann, ne.
Bist du diejenige, die das einschätzen muss?
Naja, ich kann, ich darf da, also was heißt muss, ich würde immer, also ich würde gerne ein Urteil dazu abgeben, sag ich mal, als Bankangestellter. Weil man kennt ja auch so seine Kunden und man kennt seine Pappenheimer und wie das so ist, ne. Nur wird sowas leider, bleibt sowas unberücksichtigt, so ein Hinweis.
Na ehrlich gesagt finde ich das ja ganz gut, dass das unberücksichtigt bleibt, was daraus gemacht wird, dann nicht mehr. Aber ich meine, das wäre ja noch witziger, wenn wir die Frage, ob jemand ehrlich ist, über das Gesicht regeln.
Nö, über das Gesicht, über das Kennen. Natürlich, also ich würde sowas nur aussprechen, wenn ich wirklich, wenn der jemand vor sich vertrauen hat, sag ich mal so, ne. Also sag ich mal so, wo der bei uns eine lange Geschäftsverwendung hat und wo ich sagen kann, der ist immer korrekt und also sag ich mal so, man widet ja einen Kunden. Also nicht zu jedem, sondern merkt das ja von, also ich sag mal so, das fängt damit an, wie sie eine Unterlagen unterbringen und wie sie kommen und also sag ich mal so.
Ja, ne, ich bin 33, seit 20 Jahren plan ich meinen großen Coup. Ich hab 20 Vertrauen in meiner Bank. Ich bin so nett zu denen immer, ich zahl immer alles ein und so, einfach seit 20 Jahren bau ich dieses Vertrauen zwar nicht aus.
Und die sind mit Schlips und Kragen hin, das ordentlichste Unterlagen.
Und ich sag dir noch 5 Jahre und dann kommt der Hammer.
Du wirst dich ja nicht erinnern, der, der immer so schön gewöchelt hat.
Genau, der, der immer so getan hat, als ob er beim Radio arbeitet.
Na gut, aber eins wollte ich noch mal sagen, als Empfehlung vielleicht, also so eine Sache, ich meine bei Zika geht das nun nicht, aber zum Beispiel beim Telefonbanking und beim Computerbanking und so weiter, für Leute, die sich die Heimzahl nicht merken können, versteht zum Beispiel nicht, warum die sich für jeden Falle andere aussuchen. Das sind ja so Sachen, wo man das selbst bestimmen kann.
Na ja, meine Erfahrung mit dem Telebanking bei meiner Bank war echt kurios. Ich hab sie dann halt sehr intensiv nach den Sicherheitsfeatures befragt. Und man kann sich da ein Kennwort aussuchen, so halt ein normales Wort. Irgendwie ein Gegenstand oder so was. Dann hab ich sie gefragt, wieso ich ihnen dieses Kennwort jedes Mal vollständig sagen muss. Und sie mich nicht nach dem zweiten, dritten und achten Buchstaben meines Kennworts fragen, sodass niemand, der zufällig im Raum ist, auch dieses Kennwort irgendwie mithören und dann irgendwie mein Konto abräumen könnte. Und dann meinten sie, das würde ihnen zu viel Aufwand machen. Dann hab ich sie gefragt, wieso macht ihnen das zu viel Aufwand? Na ja, es würde uns wahrscheinlich irgendwie sechsstellige Beträge kostenlos in unsere Banking Software einarbeiten zu lassen, die da in diesen Telearbeitsplätzen ist.
Dann aber doch die falsche Bank, sag ich doch.
Ja, das ist aber bei vielen, vielen, vielen Banken ganz genau so. Und es gibt nur einige wenige, die das begriffen haben.
Das ist irgendwie die richtige Bank.
Na ja, die gibt's wohl nie, denk ich mal.
Na eben, sonst zipieren wir gleich noch. Wer bricht, kann wir so weiter nicht sagen.
Ja, doch, das ist ein guter Satz.
Sag mal, Jana, aber ich find's ja doch ganz interessant, dass du... Hast du die ganze Zeit zugehört?
Nee, leider nicht.
Seit wann bist du dabei ungefähr?
Halbe, dreiviertel Stunden.
Ach, fade, dann sind die ganzen hochtechnischen Erklärungen vorher, wie das alles funktioniert, die waren dann davor. Ich hätte nämlich mal interessiert, ob du das alles wusstest, also ob das alles neu war für dich oder ob du sagst, ja klar, das weiß ich natürlich, weil ich... Gut.
Und den Poolschlüssel kannst du uns auch nicht sagen.
Weißt du, was ein Poolschlüssel ist? Ich glaube, du hast vollstes Vertrauen zum EC-Kartensystem.
Ja, wie gesagt, keine schlechten Erfahrungen.
Okay, Jan, ich hab noch eine Frage. Ich hab noch eine. Ach so, warte.
Und zwar würde mich mal interessieren, wie die offizielle Vorgehensweise ist, wenn ein Kunde kommt und sagt, er hat gerade seine EC-Karte reingeschoben, wollte für einen Markt abheben und das Ding hat gesagt, okay, und es kam kein Geld raus.
Wie die offizielle Vorgehensweise ist?
Also was machst du, wenn so ein Kunde plötzlich vor dir steht?
Also das ist so, also bei uns ist so, also wir erstmal warten müssen, ob der Automat das Geld überhaupt bucht. Weil oft ist es so, dass man automatisch merkt, dass er das Geld nicht ausgezahlt hat und keine Buchung durchführt. Sollte er es doch tun, dann sieht man es ja am nächsten Tag auf dem Kontoausdruck. Und dann wird halt vom Kunden erstmal die Reklamation entgegengenommen. Und also wir machen es bei uns so, wir nehmen die Geldautomaten ja einmal die Woche auf. Die werden also auch genau aufgenommen wie eine Kasse. Und dann stimmen die nicht.
Also aufnehmen heißt in diesem Fall, du machst sozusagen eine Inventur. Wie viel ist reingegangen, wie viel ist rausgegangen?
Genau, das gibt mehr eine Summe an, wie viel er ausgezahlt hat und wie viel also noch drin sein müsste. Und wenn mehr drin ist, kriegt der Kunde sein Geld zurück.
Und wenn nicht?
Dann sieht schlecht aus für den Kunden.
Und wie oft passiert das so bei euch?
Weil also bei meinen, also ach so, bei uns auch dreimal die Woche.
Dreimal die Woche habt ihr Differenzen in den Kassenbeständen beim Geldausgaben gemacht?
Ja und wir haben auch entsprechende Reklamationen. Bis jetzt also haben Gott sei Dank unsere Kunden immer alle zurückbekommen.
Das heißt meistens war mehr Geld drin als drin sein sollte?
Ja. Ich hatte nur einen einzigen Fall mal, wo weniger drin war.
Und was wurde da gemacht?
Na, das wurde ausgebucht auf dem Konto.
So eine schöne, so was gelernt.
Na ja, ich meine, das sind ja keine Beträge, sondern automatisch stimmt es vielleicht mal um 100.
Ach, und dann wundert man sich auch, ob das Geld drin ist.
Nein, nicht wenn man bedenkt, dass da...
Man hat den Mann umgebracht für nur 50 Mark.
Wie viel ist eigentlich drin? Sekunde, du hattest eben so einen Satz angefangen mit, wenn man sich überlegt, das.
Ja, wie viel ist denn da drin?
Also im Schnitt sage ich mal, wenn man den auffüllt, ordentlich sind 500.000 drin.
Das erklärt natürlich auch diese Rumän-Methode. Es hat ein paar Fälle gegeben, wo sie dann wirklich irgendwie mit so von den Hebebühnen von LKW-Dingen rausgekommen sind.
Habt ihr mal von dem Fall gehört, von dem Geldautomaten? Das war in Berlin hier, glaube ich. Ja, in Berlin. Da hat ein Automat immer noch eine Null rangehangen. Und das hat man, also sag mal so, wenn ein Kunde das Mark abheben wollte, hat er 1000 Euro geklaut.
Ja, das war glaube ich bei der... Wie viel hat er abgebucht?
Ja, 1000 Leiter. Aber die Leute haben abgehoben, das ist verrückt.
Na gut, es gibt ja auch noch so andere Fälle, wo Leute irgendwie schukartongweise Geld aus dem Automaten gezogen haben, dann zur Bank gegangen sind und gesagt haben, da stimmt was nicht und dann trotzdem eine Anklage bekommen haben.
Das war auch sehr interessant, Jane. Ja, wenn Jane erst seit einem Heimstand zugehört hätte, dann hat sie nie so viel bei uns gelernt wie bei ihr.
Johnny, ich will einen neuen Kopfhörer haben. Das ist grauenhaft.
Du musst mal da rüber gehen.
So was kenn ich dafür.
Ich bin ein Opfer der Technik.
Eigentlich gibt es schon lange einen Fritz-Kurz-Info.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Damm gebrochen.
Was ist denn eigentlich die Chaosradio-Kurzmeldung?
Die kommen dann nach der Musik, sobald ich einen Kopfhörer habe, der funktioniert.
Und das wieder eingeschickte Mods.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Aus aktuellen Gründen verspätet, 0 Uhr 34.
Hochwasseralarm. Im Oderbruch müssen die Einwohner von etwa 40 weiteren Ortschaften evakuiert werden. Betroffen sind rund 15.000 Menschen. Grund ist ein neuer Deichhutsch bei Hohenwutzen. Hubschrauber flogen pausenlos Sand zum Deich. Am Abend konnten auch wieder Soldaten der Bundeswehr eingesetzt werden, die zunächst aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht an der Gefahrenstelle arbeiten durften. Auch über eine provisorische angelegte Straße wurde Material herangeschafft. Und jetzt eine aktuelle Bekanntgabe der Orte, die heute Nacht evakuiert werden. Alt Wrietzen, Wurigar, Heinrichsdorf, Kerstenbruch, Eichwerder, Neu-Levin-Buchhof, Lohse, Thöringes Werder, Gießhof, Felner Lohse, Sofienhof, Alte Levin, Bliedorf, Kunersdorf, Neu-Bahnim, Alt Rebin, Ortwig, die Bahnimdörfer Groß, Klein und Alt, Groß Neuendorf, Metzdorf, Klein Neuendorf, Neu-Trebien, Wuschwier, Gottersgabe, Neuendorfer Lohse, Sietzing, Neu-Friedland, Kienitz, Wilhelmsauer, Alt Friedland, Kienwerder, Quappendorf, Neu-Hartenberg, die Verteiler davon, Ich bin von der Winkel Neurosenthal, Lechin, Grusualose, Bladko und alle in diesen Gebieten liegenden Einzelbehörfte sind von der Evakuierung betroffen. Absage. Israel hat alle Gespräche mit der palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde offiziell unterbrochen. Das Kabinett reagierte damit auf den Bombenanschlag in Jerusalem, der 15 Menschen leben und mehr als 150 Verletzte gefordert hat. Inzwischen bekannte sich die radikale islamische Hamas zu dem Blutbad. Schuldspruch. Fünf ehemalige DDR-Offiziere sind zu Bewährungsstrafen zwischen neun Monaten und eineinhalb Jahren verurteilt worden. Wegen ihrer Mitverantwortung für die Selbstschussanlagen an der Grenze erkannte das Berliner Landgericht auf Beihilfe zum Totschlag. Angebot. Die Brandenburger Landesregierung will zum 1. Oktober 50 zusätzliche Lehrstellen in so genannten Kammerberufen bereitstellen. Dabei handelt es sich unter anderem um Fachinformatiker und Kaufleute für Bürokommunikation.
Wetter.
Nach 17 bis 14 Grad am Tage wolkig, einzelne Schauer bis 24 Grad.
Verkehr.
Gibt es nichts Aktuelles?
Das war Kerstin Koch mit den Fritz Kurz Info und jetzt gibt es die Kurzmeldungen. Ja, jetzt die Kurzmeldungen.
Kurzmeldungen.
Chaosradio Kurzmeldungen. Internet. Die ersten Versuche unerwünschte Inhalte im Internet per Contentfiltering zu blockieren, zeigen etliche Risiken und Nebenwirkungen. Da die meisten der Programme, die unschuldige Kinder vor den Gefahren des Netzes schützen sollen, auf der Basis von dumfer Stichwort-Suche arbeiten, sind dann schon mal die Server von Sussex County Fair, Middlesex County College oder dem Essex County College unerreichbar. Ein Sprecher der Firma NetNanny, die eines der betroffenen Produkte herstellt, meinte dazu, dass einige Nutzer offenbar das Handbuch nicht gelesen hätten. San Francisco. Der Versuch, Kinderficker mit moderner Technologie das Handwerk zu legen, ist im sonnigen Kalifornien offenbar gründlich in die Hose gegangen. Auf einer CD-ROM für die Polizeibehörden, die Beschreibungen, Namen und Adressen von entlassenen Sexualtätern enthält, sind deutlich mehr als die Hälfte der Daten veraltet, falsch, unbrauchbar sortiert oder einfach nicht zur Veröffentlichung bestimmt. Die CD-ROM sollte auf den Polizeirevieren der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht werden. Beobachtungen der Polizei zufolge hat alleine die Existenz der CD-ROM zu einem massiven Abtauchen betroffener Leute in den Untergrund geführt. In mindestens einem Fall wurde das Auto eines entlassenen Täters mit einem Molotov Cocktail abgefackelt. Paris. Das Fliegen mit Air France bietet neben Wanzen in der ersten Klasse auch noch andere Belustigungen. Kürzlich wurde ein Passagier von Anna Stewardess mit heruntergelassenen Hosen aus der Toilette gezerrt, die ihn vor allen anderen Fluggästen des Rauchens auf der Toilette bezichtigte. Der Passagier war nicht Raucher. Die Ursache der brachialen Aktion wahrscheinlich ein defekter Rauchmelder auf dem Klo oder eine Verwechslung von zwei gegenüberliegenden Establishments. Die übliche Multimillionen Dollar Erschadensersatzklage ist schon unterwegs. Saudi Arabien. Ahnungslose Zuschauer eines französischen Nachrichtenprogramms wurden Opfer einer Kanalverwechslung auf einem Satelliten von France Telecom. Statt der erwarteten Nachrichten gab es über etwa 20 Minuten Gerammle und Gestöhne vom härtesten. Das Hardcore-Pornoprogramm hätte eigentlich im Aboprogramm von Kanal Plus übertragen werden sollen. Saudi Arabien Satellitengesellschaft Arabsat kündigte daraufhin seine Verträge mit France Telecom. Begründet wurde der Schritt mit der ungenügenden Respektierung arabischer und islamischer Werte durch die France Telecom. Und nochmal Internet. Der massive Ausfall weiter Teile der Netzinfrastruktur vorletzte Woche im Internet war auf eine interessante Kombination von Fehlern zurückzuführen, die die Legende vom atomkriegsicheren Netz endgültig als Lüge entlarven. Im zentralen Nameserver des Internets, Internic, wurde ein falsches Zonenfile für die Router generiert, das keine Einträge für Rechner enthielt, die auf.net und.com enden. Daraufhin war die Mehrzahl dieser Server über Stunden bis zu mehreren Tagen nicht erreichbar. Um die Krise etwas zu verschärfen, wurden an zwei Stellen der USA mehrere Dutzend Glasfaserkabel bei Bauarbeiten durchtrennt. Die Folge war ein fast vollständiger Brownout des Netzes. Unbestätigten Gerüchten zur Folge wurden in jenen Tagen die Budgets für die beschleunigte Einführung von TCP IP Version 6 deutlich erhöht.
Fritz präsentiert geballte Action und haufenweise Pferdestärken. Die Rallye Monte Lugau. Wahnsinn auf zwei Rädern. Das ultimative Rennen für Schwalben und Duos. Zwei Kilometer knallharte Hochspannung mit Feuerwehrspikane und Friedhofskurve. Die Gefahr lauert überall. Live mit dabei, Ro, Rallye und The Klotz. Die Rallye Monte Lugau. Samstag, 9. August, ab 11 Uhr in Lugau bei Finsterwalde. Erstmals ohne Startgebühr. Aber natürlich mit schockierender Schwalben-Hochgeschwindigkeitsgarantie und......Furz.
So, noch 20 Minuten Chaos Radio der Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Im Chat sage ich übrigens schon seit geraumer Zeit nichts mehr, die, die im Chat sitzen, wissen warum. Und zwar genau seit dem Moment, in dem ich gesagt hab, dass ich nichts mehr sage. Pfff, was das irgendjemand versteht. Wenn nicht, ist auch egal, ist der Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club hier bei Fritz.
Hier leuchtet auch schon wieder so ein Lämmchen.
Echt?
Hier leuchtet ein Lämmchen.
Vor einer Stunde haben wir noch weiter telefonieren.
Ja eigentlich ein bisschen Klärungsbedarf gibt es, ne?
Genau. Wir wollten ja nämlich noch was dazu sagen, was wir uns jetzt insgesamt überlegt haben. Und das ist nämlich diesen Poolschlüssel, weil irgendwie uns immer noch kein Hörer diesen Poolschlüssel durchgegeben hat, dass wir den jetzt einfach mal ausrechnen. Und weil der Trick ist ja der, dass wenn man den jetzt einmal hat, dann kann man damit a. diese Behauptung der Banken, es geht eben nicht, und so weiter und so fort in dem Bereich der Märchen endlich mal de facto katapultieren. naja, kann man dann sozusagen auch gleich mal gucken, dass man diese Haftungsfrage vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders geregelt bekommt. Weil es gibt zwar dieses Gerichtsurteil des ULWG Hamm, aber es gibt auch danach schon wieder ein kleines Urteil, das anders ausgefallen ist. Und das ist also nach wie vor ein bisschen eine unsichere Position des Verbrauchers.
Ja, vielleicht soll man gleich noch mal zur Klärung sagen. Ausrechnen ist ein bisschen übertrieben bei der Geschichte. Also man kann den Poolschlüssel nicht direkt ausrechnen, wie vorhin auch ein Hörer gefragt hat. Aber man kann einfach alle zwei hoch 56 Möglichkeiten durchprobieren. Wie gesagt, 56 dritt ist der Schlüssel lang. Und schon 1993 wurde von einem Michael Wiener ein Paper veröffentlicht, in dem er eine komplette Hardware-Beschreibung für einen ASIC beschrieben hat, für eine sogenannte programmierbare Logik, die für einen minimalen Geldaufwand kleiner als eine Million einen solchen Deskschlüssel und einen solchen Handelssicher beim Poolschlüssel ermittelt. Und zwar durch ausprobieren.
Das würde dann wie lange dauern?
Das kommt ganz darauf an, wie viel man da investiert. Wenn man, sagen wir, 300.000 Dollar in das Projekt investieren würde, dann hätte man erstens die Entwicklungszeit, bis man in solche Maschinen baut. Und dann würde es vielleicht 20 Tage, einen Monat dauern, bis der Schlüssel auch wirklich da ist. Je mehr Geld man da reinsteckt, desto schneller geht das. Das wechselt prinzipiell in die Art. Die hauptsächlichen Kosten sind die Kosten für die Entwicklung des Kredits. Die sind fest und dann kann man noch beliebig viel Geld dafür da reinstecken, den Rechner weiter ausbauen und bekommt eine Schüssel entsprechend schneller. Ist aber egal, weil wir bloß eine Schüssel ausrechnen müssen, nämlich den Push-Schüssel.
Okay, aber wir haben uns ja sozusagen nicht dafür entschlossen, diese verteilte Rechtengeschichte übers Internet zu machen, sondern wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir tatsächlich eigentlich mal so eine Maschine bauen wollen, weil der Algorithmus dieser DS, der wird ja noch bei vielen, vielen anderen Sachen verwendet, bei Homebanking-Geschichten, bei Verschlüsselungsgeschichten ganz allgemein und sofort. Und die Geheimdienste, auch die deutschen, auch der BND zum Beispiel, hat schon seit Jahren mehrere, also die haben zwei so riesige Maschinen von Thinking Machine Cooperation, für die sie zwei Millionenbeträge hingelicht haben, mit denen sie aber in unter zehn Sekunden so einen DASH-Schlüssel ausrechnen können. Nun haben wir zwar deren Etat nicht ganz, aber mittlerweile sind die Hardwarepreise da auch ein bisschen gefallen, sodass wir mit, sagen wir mal, Kosten von unter einer Million Mark realistisch rechnen, wobei sich die Diskussion, also wie das jetzt genau technisch ablaufen wird, die werden wir auf HIP führen, also sozusagen Ende nächster Woche in Holland, auf www.hip.com.90, um es nochmal gesagt zu haben.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man noch darauf eingehen, wo die Bedeutung ist, wenn so eine Maschine gebaut wird, und zwar werden die Schäden durch EC-Karten Missbrauch insgesamt auf 200 Millionen geschätzt, das kann man glauben oder nicht, aber 200 Millionen ist auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr als die Millionen, die man braucht, um eine solche Maschine zu bauen, sodass es wahrscheinlich sich rechnen würde, für die organisierte Kriminalität zu einer Maschine zu bauen und dann im großen Maßstab EC-Karten zu missbrauchen. Das könnte ein lohnendes Geschäft gewesen sein.
Ja, ich könnte gar behaupten, dass es eben längst geschehen ist.
Jetzt würde ich gerne nochmal zum Abschluss der Sendung, die ja demnächst vorbei ist, von euch hören. Was es denn für Alternativen gibt, eurer Meinung nach?
Alternativen?
Ich wäre nochmal das geplante neue System.
Also was die Banken jetzt machen, ist zum einen diesen Pool-Schlüssel, diesen 56-Bit-Pool-Schlüssel sozusagen abzuschaffen, wie sie behaupten oder wie sie sagen. Das heißt, dass man, das ist ein zweistufiges Konzept, ich müsste jetzt ein bisschen glättern aus dem Kopf heraus, machen die also folgendes, die schalten im Prinzip auf einen 128-Bit-Schlüssel um, der allerdings auch nur noch institutsabhängig ist. Das heißt, es gibt keinen übergreifenden Schlüssel mehr, der im Automaten geheim abgespeichert ist, sondern es gibt nur noch Institutschlüssel und Online-Connectivity. Also wenn man an einem Geldautomaten eines fremden Instituts ist, stellt der dann eben eine Datenverbindung zu seinem eigenen Institut hier, überträgt die Geschichten und lässt es da dann berechnen oder so. Ja, und es soll zwar noch die Möglichkeit geben, beispielsweise am Ausland dann, weil da haben sie ja nicht überall online, Geld abzuheben. Es gibt also schon noch irgendeine Form von Poolschlüssel. Der befindet sich dann allerdings auf der Chipkartenfunktion, die diese Karte, diese EC-Karte in der Zukunft ja auch hat, wegen der elektronischen Geldbörse, also wegen diesem quasi Geldspeicher, der da noch in der Chipkarte aufgebracht ist.
Im Chat fragt einer, warum man nicht einfach ein 128 KB Schlüssel entwickelt?
128 Bit, ja tut man ja. Also die schalten auf 128 Bit Institutschlüssel um und schaffen den 56 Bit Poolschlüssel.
Nur noch europaweit durchziehen, wenn sie auch wirklich den Fuß in Amerika fassen wollen.
Naja, also die...
Es ist auf jeden Fall noch nicht klar, ob dieser neue Ansatz wirklich eine Lösung des Problems darstellt. Im Prinzip ist auch dieser neue Schlüssel durchaus hackbar, auch wenn es sich jetzt um mehr als ein handelt. Und wenn erstmal klar ist, wie es geht, dann ist es alles nur noch eine Frage der Skalierung der Systeme, mit dem man das schon mal geschafft hat.
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt alle am Radio gefragt habt, was das eigentlich alles soll, Aufruf zur Kriminalität natürlich nicht. Unter anderem ist eine Aufgabe und eines der Ziele des Chaos Computer Clubs, vielleicht, dass man so stellvertretend irgendwie sagen darf, solche Geschichten zu machen, um eben dafür zu sorgen, dass solche Sicherheitssysteme zum Beispiel verbessert werden oder verändert werden. Deswegen war ich vorhin so ein bisschen, wenn jemand sagt, ich vertraue da voll, weil ich vertraue den Banken, nichts muss da noch passieren.
Oder gar nicht erst gebaut werden.
Oder gar nicht erst gebaut werden. Wenn sich niemand darum kümmert und aufzeigt, wo eventuell Lücken sind, wie man das ja auch von Software kennt und so weiter, dann wird auch nie was verbessert werden. So, das wird ein bisschen moral.
Aber jetzt noch mal zu deiner Frage zurück, wie könnte man es irgendwie besser machen? Ich meine, es steht ja außer Zweifel, dass so Geldautomaten, also die Ersetzung von Schalterbeamten durch Geldautomaten eine Menge Personalkosten sparen, eine Menge für Jahren sparen und so weiter und so fort. Und das heißt, die Banken machen da von sich aus schon mal eine Menge Gewinn. Und sie sollen doch bitteschön einfach die Technologie, die sie dann einführen, sozusagen da auch die Risiken tragen und die dann nicht auch noch dem Kunden aufkommen. Weil Geld sparen sie ja ohnehin. Und dann können sie dieses Geld auch sinnvoll einsetzen, nämlich um die Löcher zu stopfen oder um doch zumindest das, was durch die Löcher flutscht, irgendwie zu finanzieren.
In der Banken-Szene gibt es ja diesen schönen Ausdruck der rentablen Sicherheit, die sie mit ihren Systemen bieten wollen. Das sagt natürlich schon alle.
Also doch, ich hab ja recht.
In diesem Sinne, telefonieren können wir leider nicht mehr, weil die Sendung gleich vorbei ist. Ja, wir haben ein paar Minuten, aber wenn wir jetzt anfangen zu telefonieren, überziehen wir dann. Hast mal was kurzes, Andi.
Jetzt kommst du gerade in Fahrung.
Wir haben noch unsere Datenschweiler-Dervi-Minute. Genau, dann machen wir die doch jetzt.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen Farbung und dann gibt es Musik. Und dann kommt Martin mit dem Night Flight.
Gut, also weitere Informationen?
Ach so, hier macht die Statistik auch, wenn ihr jetzt noch sucht. Hier Statistik, also wir haben zwölfmal die eins gehabt, sechsmal die zwei, viermal die drei, fünfmal die vier, zweimal die fünf und jeweils einmal die sechs, die acht und die neun. Die sieben kam gar nicht vor als erste Ziffer von eurem PIN-Code zu Hause. Es sind insgesamt 32 Nennungen, zwölfmal davon die eins, sind also über 30 Prozent in diesem Fall. Die sechs sind dann etwa die zwei, als erste Ziffer waren etwa fünf Prozent.
Und wenn ihr weitere Informationen wollt, dann guckt ihr entweder mal in die Newsgroup.de.org.ccc oder auf www.ccc.de oder kommt einfach nächstes Wochenende nach Holland zu hip97. Dazu Infos auf www.hip97.nl Und wenn ihr irgendwie noch an dieses Papiermedium Interesse habt, an unserer Datenscheune, dann schickt einfach mal C-Mark für ein Probe-Abo nach Hamburg zum CCC in die Schwenke-Straße. 85 in 20255 Hamburg.
Ja, das sieht so so aus.
Ihr könnt uns aber auch gerne jederzeit den Pool-Schlüssel mitteilen unter der E-Mail-Adresse chaos.urb.de Da gibt's dann auch noch ein T-Shirt für Dirk, auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht sogar noch ein Basecap dazu.
Und ein Aufkleber. Aber eine Bitte auch noch wegen E-Mails an uns. Bitte schickt keine Dateien mit. Das nervt total.
Wir nehmen gerne eure Mods entgegen, aber nach Vereinbarung.
Macht Vereinbarung oder sagt uns zur FDP-Sache.
Es gibt eine E-Mail-Adresse dafür, die steht bei uns auch auf der Website. Das ist chaosklavier.berlin.ccc.de. Wichtig ist dabei, dass Berlin. Am besten noch mal auf der Webseite. Da kann man Watt-Faß-Entschuldigung. Da hab ich auch schon welche empfangen. Ich hab heute noch mal einen Brief bekommen von Nils, der sich beschwert hat, dass ich über so eine E-Mail nicht geantwortet habe. Das hätte ich im Chaos untergegangen. Allerdings werden manche Mods, du machst das auch ganz gerne, in merkwürdigen Archiven abgespeichert. Ich glaube, es waren RAR-Files. Das ist immer noch mal ein kleines Hindernis für den Macintosh-Benutzer. Aber wir schauen natürlich auch in Zukunft in eure Mails.
Ja, und nicht so große Dateien schicken, bzw. gar keine Dateien schicken, sondern irgendwas vereinbaren, oder auf einem FTP-Serve oder so. Da werden wir uns irgendwas einfallen lassen, wenn ihr dann mailt. Und Tim ist ziemlich eifrig im Mail beantworten. Was denn jetzt hier?
Ja.
Welche denn?
Vier.
Vier, warte mal. Nimm ich die andere raus. Soll ich noch Mod spielen? Na, dann nicht. Dann hier noch für den guten Freund aus Hamburg, wie er immer heißt. Sven Dose? Den kenne ich doch auch vorher. War der schon mal hier? Ach, die Party damals, wo ich war. Die vier.
Da warst du mit Kuttner übrigens.
Guck an, auf welcher Party? Das sehen wir dir nach. Aha, die Party, da war ich mit Kuttner, guck an. Na, ich war wahrscheinlich übersehen.
Gute Nacht.
Da hängt es sich manchmal an. Ja, schön gute Nacht noch vom Chaos Computer Club und von Johnny. Viel Spaß mit Martin in Night Flight. Und Chaos Computer Club, Chaos Radio, den Computerblumen bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Was ist ein Thema in der nächsten Sendung?
Wahrscheinlich die HIP und die Themen, die dort aufgekommen sind. Da wird es eine Menge Neues geben. Parallel zu der HIP findet im Übrigen auch in Amerika eine große Hacker-Convention statt. Die heißt Beyond Hope. Letztes Mal hieß sie Hope, jetzt Beyond Hope. Hope steht für Hackers on Planet Earth. Die wird zeitgleich stattfinden. Und es wird eine relativ gute Coverage geben im Internet. Man sollte also nochmal auf diese HIP-Seiten schauen. Die beiden Veranstaltungen werden quergeschaltet. Und das wird alles ganz lustig. Bis dann.
Das ist zwei Minuten nach eins. Ganz getragene Anfang heute im Night Flight auf Fritz in der Nacht von Mittwoch auf Donnerstag. Schönen guten Abend sagt Martin Petersdorf. Das waren Echo and the Bunnyman, I'll Fly Tonight. Schön, dass sich die Bands immer passende Songs zu den Sendungen einfallen lassen. Echo and the Bunnyman aus ihrer neuen Platte Evergreen, die allerdings hier in Deutschland erst, ich glaube so Ende August, Anfang September erscheinen wird. In Großbritannien und Amerika gibt es die Platte schon, deshalb auch natürlich bei euch im Radio. Und mehr von Echo and the Bunnyman heute Abend, Soundgarden, ab 20 Uhr. Da liegt aber noch ein bisschen was dazwischen, zum Beispiel knapp drei Stunden Night Flight noch, bis morgen zum Vier. In der gewohnten Mischung heute mit einer etwas längeren Geburtstagsrunde mal wieder, für den 31. Juli, war ein guter Tag. Gegen zwei beglückwünscht man dann diverse Musiker. Und in der letzten halben Stunde gibt es wie gewohnt einen kleinen Mix aus fünf so genannten Popperlen. Schön, dass noch ein paar Nachtollen dabei sind. Und ich hoffe ihr bleibt noch ein bisschen. Also Schuhe aus bzw. Stiefel aus und gemütlich gemacht. Hier ist Terry AdWords und seine Skategoats Boots. Terry Edwards, ganz früher mal Saxophonist bei Serious Drinking. Mittlerweile spielt er unter anderem bei Jimmy Tenor und gehört fest zum Line-Up von Gallant Drunk. Dies ist ein Stück, das er mit seiner eigenen Band in Scapegoats aufgenommen hat. Boots Off ist die neue Single von Terry Edwards und wird dann demnächst auch auf seinem Album zu finden sein. Copper Girl, exzellente neue Single aus Kopplung aus dem Debütalbum von Three Colors Red. Klingt zwar teilweise so im Referral mal ein bisschen nach Fischer-Set, aber bei der nächsten Nummer wird es noch ein bisschen komischer. Das ist nämlich die neue Single von den Stereophonics und wenn man da mal genau hinhört, Bon Jovi ist nicht weit entfernt. A Thousand Trees. A Thousand Trees, dritte Single der Stereophonics. Das Debütalbum gibt's dann Ende August und da werden wir dann in einem etwas ausführlicheren Interview mit den Stereophonics auch erfahren, warum die denn so nach Schweine Rock klingen. Bis dahin muss man noch ein bisschen abwarten. Aus Oxford.
I'll play keyboards and sing a little, and you're listening to Martin on Fritz.
Die Hand an der Wiege, The Hand that Rocks the Cradle. Corduroy aus London aus ihrem aktuellen Album The New You. Und davor hatten wir aus Oxford The Bigger the God und deren Single When Martin Met Martin. Bis zum Fritz Kurz in Fall die neue Band von Davy Woodward, war früher mal bei den Brilliant Corners.
Experimental Pop Band und London Pregnancy Test 1976 aus der neuen Platte Disgrotesque. 1, 30 Uhr, halb zwei. Hochwasseranlaam. Im Oderbruch müssen die Einwohner von etwa 40 weiteren Ortschaften evakuiert werden. Betroffen sind rund 15.000 Menschen. Grund ist ein neuer Deichrutsch bei Hohenwutzen. Hubschrauber flogen pausenlos dann zum Deich. Am Abend konnten auch wieder Soldaten der Bundeswehr eingesetzt werden, die zunächst aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht an der Gefahrenstelle arbeiten durften. Auch über eine provisorisch angelegte Straße wurde Material herangeschafft. Israel hat alle Gespräche mit der palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde offiziell unterbrochen. Das Kabinett reagierte damit auf den Bombenanschlag in Jerusalem, der 15 Menschen leben und mehr als 150 Verletzte gefordert hat. Inzwischen bekannte sich die radikale islamische Hamas zu dem Blutbad. Da war ich schon vorsichtig. Justin Koch und ein kurzes Info. Schön vorsichtig. Fritz präsentiert Big Beats in Berlin. The Chemical Brothers. Live in Berlin. Windetisiert, katalysiert und explodiert durch. Martin Petersdorf und Vista, was wir schon fast eine Woche nicht mehr hatten.